this show is brought to you by seed geek
seed geek is always the first place I go
when I'm looking for tickets and they're
offering our listeners a 20 rebate off
of their first heat geek purchase to get
the 20 rebate you download the free
SeatGeek app you go to the settings tab
click add a promo code and use promo
code church and see geek will send you
twenty dollars after you've made your
first ticket purchase let's download the
free C geek app and enter promo code
church today
shows also brought to you by datsu Sara
go to dsgear.com and use Cobra Joey to
get five percent off of their extremely
high quality functional gear that's made
with hemp textiles they have bags skis
rash guards and much much more it's DS
gear.com and use Cobra Joey to save five
percent off and use code word on it and
I'll go to onit.com and use code word
church to save 10 on all their great
optimization products like Alpha Brain
new mood immune and zoom dexport
um
oh [__]
Sunday night early Monday morning
a little kiss for you [__]
there's a kiss my little Disco
bubble teamed it a little bit Ace
growing heat listen
what
tonight
I want to stick it in your eyes I love
it the church [__]
Sunday
Monday
July 11th it's a whole new [__] week
it's a straight week There's No [__]
up holiday on Monday you're walking
around Wednesday thinking it's Thursday
it's just gonna be a beautiful [__]
week Lisa yet my other little brother
Eddie Bravo in the house oh [__] [__]
Vegas driving back signing autographs at
UFC pass people telling me people
wouldn't leave you alone at the [__]
comedy show
asking if you want to go to experiment
right on YouTube
[__] crazy people out there aren't
that those things they're crazy they go
out there to lose their minds
I was smoking a [__] number
talking land hidden under a bridge
as six people came home we were [__]
draped and [__] uh what's that
camouflage and people still found this
in the [__] weeds though it was Vegas
crazy this weekend it must have been
yeah it was crazy the fan listen The Fan
Expo
is fun as [__]
you know how many I mean I went the
first year
how was it this year it was good yeah
back yeah it was uh it's grown it's
bigger and bigger they have like
wrestling tournaments kickboxing
tournaments that MMA events going on I
mean the space that they rent for this
is like
oh man it's like Lollapalooza or
something you know what I mean or or a
Coachella it's just a giant [__] I
mean they had an ibjf full-blown
tournament going on with multiple mats
and
um they had like an eight-man super
fight thing too uh they had
karate tournaments it was [__] huge
man it was crazy
I was gonna fly in Thursday and go
Friday morning but I had to go to the
doctor at 9 15.
just took the 12 30 flight and said [__]
it
but I wanted to walk around I just
wanted to see it wasn't even the
fighters as much as the other [__] they
got there that you go wow martial arts
has come a long [__] way mouthpieces
that are made out of this you know
whatever they just have [__] that you
know I didn't see as a [__] kid I
used to go to those martial arts stores
every [__] Saturday and just sit
there and drool I'm gonna put away money
and come back and get a star
then they sold you Aston it wasn't
sharpened that drove you [__] nuts
you were thrown against the wall 80
times it wouldn't stick you're like what
the [__] then somebody was like what are
you stupid you gotta get it sharp now
you gotta go down to the [__]
hardware store and give the guy with the
missing finger five bucks and he puts it
in like a [__] um thing you know like
a thing that closes yeah and then he
would hit it
that's how you get them sharpened what
are you gonna do somebody said to bring
them home and do them in your mother's
can opener
remember that [__] can opener your
mom had that the back of it was a knife
sharpener
I had one of those knife sharpening like
swords or sticks I never I don't know
how to use them I spent time as a kid
you know you can't well that I had
nunchucks as a kid but it was the uh
rubber with the foam kind like I never
got like actual good ones what about I
guess it was a collie stick when I did
Taekwondo my my master had like a huge
long wooden stick that he would just
whack that's what they were if we were
doing something wrong
like that like that was the best like
that's what I always wanted a Golly's
thing just just to hit my little brother
yeah [__] crazy yeah you know it's
funny because today Chinese connection
was on somebody says I'm watching the
Bruce Lee
and I turned it on
and it was the part where he was about
to hang the [__] dude
which is just a a violation of a martial
arts film
like this was the early early martial
art films and Bruce Lee hangs this
[__] he hangs two of them on one
day then another [__] on the
third dude that's Clint Eastwood type
[__] and like the the one Hang Em High
one of those
one of those he Paints the town red I
don't know what the [__] movie is
don't quote me here oh Joey you're wrong
I don't know one of those Italian movies
he did was really he was really evil he
was very evil and this movie Bruce Lee
is evil
so I'm sitting there I'm watching it and
I'm watching it I'm watching I'm
watching when he goes and he's watching
the Japanese guys train he's watching
the Russian train and now I see him go
for the kill and I put on Periscope and
I put him on show them and I narrated it
Eddie bravois is one of the greatest
martial art runs he goes through 40
[__]
if you understand me but he says a line
that is so unique
he looks at the school and he goes
listen I come here to avenge my master
this has nothing to do with you I'm
allowing you
to leave
it's like me coming into your house and
going hey I'm allowing you to leave
and they were like we don't know what
the [__] they're sweeping the mat
mopping the map he just threw a beating
on those guys he stabs the black belt
with a [__] sword
he comes outside he does a spinning
elbow who does the spinning elbow in
I understand
walks directly and Spins that he pops
comes back kicks the guy goes and beats
the [__] out of three more guys
bodyguards then he [__] up the Russian
dude then he goes in and when he goes in
to fight the master the master has a
sword
Bruce Lee took out new Chucks and for a
minute it was like I was 10 years old is
that seen on YouTube or something I'm
sure it is
Chinese connection the ending scene but
the beauty of it is that he when he took
those new chunks and goosebumps I got
tears in my eyes
because I still remember the first time
he broke those new chunks out America
lost their mind
like it's very hard to describe as an
old man but I feel proud that I saw it
like he put the new chunks out on a
Friday and by Monday [__] had
new trucks not the [__] good ones
either the homemade ones
how do you make homemade nunchucks you
take a broom
you cut it measure it completely even
and then you get eye hooks
and you screw the eye hook into the
[__] thing on top and you get a
little six inch chain and you start
practicing that's a homemade
[__] new Chuck put that put that
fight scene on okay the YouTube uh let
me see if this is it
it's two minutes it's probably it no no
this isn't it go back this is the ending
you gotta go to go back and I'll tell
you that was part three maybe that was a
part one right here the fourth one
change the national fight scene okay
guys this is something that
just look at him this is 1971. he's
[__] Steve McQueen coached they gave
him a picture that said sick man of Asia
and he walks back to the [__]
Japanese school and he says take this
[__] from me now
kick the volume on this lead
this is based in the 40s when Japanese
oppressed the Chinese take this from me
and then get out of here
whenever you're ready I'll take on any
Japanese here now any Bravo to you
you're like Joey why are you making me
watch this because no I want to watch it
I want I want you to put yourself in
1971.
okay nobody was doing anything close to
this you and Clint Eastwood Charles
Bronson
here ever got like laid because of it
this was something that I don't these
movies cost maybe 50 000 a make in
Thailand they made Millions on this move
[Music]
look at this guy's wig
the fight scene itself I saw on a
Wednesday in Catholic School
and it was coming out Friday like this
was the trailer during Happy Days
and I lost my mind in Catholic School
how old were you eight oh yeah of course
lost my [__] mind when they picked me
up they asked me what I wanted to do
that week and it was to go see this
and the movie theater was passed look at
this [__] like everybody got to see this
not just Fist of Fury the first one did
kind of weird this one
swept across the [__] board
to this day that shirt that he wears
it's one of the coolest outfits I always
used to get that right you have to get
the white shirt with the long long long
sleeves then the blue shirt and then you
roll the white sleeves up over the blue
shirt
and he probably eight years old here we
go
I'm studying with Rashad's father and
I'm seeing this [__]
are you kidding me
like you believe it it's like that that
could happen
oh I lost my [__] mind
I don't know
look at this and he Quarry ass graphed
everything
right here look at this look the money
the money right here
oh [__] that's money right there a
double punch backwards
watch how they turn into dummy this is
old school but here you go this was
history guys this is history right here
everybody in the movie theater went oh
[__]
look at it this is history right here
right now you're at the movie theater
you're hard to bleeding your
heart's pumping your hands are sweating
you can't wait for this movie to end so
you can figure out how to get nutrients
you will look in Black Belt Magazine you
lost your [__] money
[Applause]
that guy right there that guy's name was
John Reese he was one of the best
traditional Taekwondo guys at the time
he's not even sweating
no
no that was classic
now
that destroyed American guys so you went
home and you made the wooden ones and
then people figured out wait a second
you gotta get the thickest dick
and then they did that one with the
chain but then a movie called Corrado
the Hong Kong cat came out
when Bruce Lee died the first wannabe
movie that you cannot find
because I've looked for this
[__] was it Bruce Lie No it was
his other good looking Chinese kid but
the opening scene is him [__] up like
13 kids and his mom's like Corrado time
for dinner and they're like all right
see you tomorrow like they did this
every [__] day for Corrado
and Corrado's new chunks had tips at the
end
that destroyed America let's see if we
can find that Corrado the Hong Kong cat
oh [__] how crazy was it that this is
1974. this is probably 1973 a few months
after Bruce Lee died or right before
Bruce Lee died they said step aside
Bruce Lee
and Make Way for Corrado the Hong Kong
cat oh Hong Kong or Hong Kong Hong Kong
whatever the [__] it is Hong Kong you
know it was from Hong Kong what about
Bruce [__] lie they were trying to
get him to they needed someone to look
like Bruce Lee kind of sound like Bruce
Lee we just changed one letter at the
end and they were hoping like like Kiss
they hope that the masses won't even
notice the difference you know like with
Ace Freely and with Peter Chris they got
a different dude to play ace release
same makeup and a different dude to play
Peter Chris same makeup and they you
know the fans the real fans know it
right what the [__] going on but but
like the fair weather fans go oh let's
go check out kiss they're in town
they're not gonna have any idea they
they're they're they're counting on that
isn't that crazy the whole thing's on
YouTube let's just see what this is
though oh [__] the Hong Kong cat let's
just see if this is
he's got the same shirt and everything
you listen to my words and crawl under
both my legs then I'll let you go huh
you're witty enough
better crawl under my legs or else
You'll Never Walk go to hell get him
why are his hands in his pocket
because he's that badass
oh my God this is so bad
[Applause]
it's the worst [__] ever after
it you know they just threw out
there was a time period where they
called black exploitation movies
well
they started putting these on and when
Bruce Lee died they were putting these
out [__] tell them keep going keep
going keep going I just want to see if
he breaks out his new Chuck that doesn't
seem the same guy
It's gotta be his name is Corrado listen
they could have made a fake Corrado too
you never [__] know with these people
these people were Savages in the 70s man
dude this is news to me I never heard of
Corrado Bruce Lee opened up Bruce Lee's
death opened up every
see this is the German version
[Music]
you know I loved all these movies but
once Bruce Lee died that was it I was I
was not one of the ones that got one of
one of my funniest Eddie's conversations
ever was about 10 years ago
but the guy who pitched
game of death for
like the balls on that guy yeah what are
you doing we don't want to waste your
time for that we have an idea of a game
of death for
um listen again but listen you know yeah
Game of Death two made two million
dollars and Game of Death three made 10
million dollars this we're going to use
a black guy and put Bruce Lee's face
over it that sounds interesting what is
your production value about 10 22.50
because that's what it's going to cost
to shoot that they ended up shooting
like eight game of debts that's crazy
the first the first one was crazy enough
let me tell you something the first game
of death is one of the worst movies you
will ever see in your [__] life yes
you know there's different reports that
he
started losing his mind towards the end
you know like little things and when you
watch that movie it solidifies that well
he Bruce Lee was actually only in the
last scene the scene where he fights
Korean Bill Jabbar and uh Danny and I
saw now he's he goes up from Level he
had shot that then he died
and they uh they wanted to they had
one tenth of the movie and they figured
you know what we could do this we could
put this [__] out he died in 73 Game of
Death came out in 1977. they they had a
uh a fake Kareem Abdul-Jabbar a fake
Bruce Lee to play the whole movie except
the end the real Bruce Lee comes in it
was pretty [__] ridiculous it was
[__] embarrassing it was [__] in my
world it was [__] embarrassing I
wouldn't go I wouldn't fall for it put
the Game of Death find Game of Death
that'd be better because you could see
the fake Bruce Lee
see that this reef is kicking tonight
[__] I can't believe I got to be in
surgery and [__] 11 hours goddamn
Eddie
for some reason I'm scared of this
[__] surgery though
I think this is the game no this is the
last thing this is going to be the
actual
part that Bruce Lee's in
yeah he's actually in this can you find
the movie Game of Death
you want like the whole thing uh let's
see what we got because what they're
doing is they're actually showing the
parts that he was actually in but most
of the movie he wasn't in yeah right
there that Bruce Lee Game of Death right
there
yeah look look what he's dead for four
years and they decided
um
they open they open the movie with the
Chuck the scene with Chuck Norris from
that's really Bruce Lee but that movie
was Return of the Dragon and then it
turns out that this Movie Game of Death
is about like Bruce Lee like a superstar
Asian action film star and he's filming
here and then they say cut they'll say
cut and then oh they were filming them
the scene and all of a sudden it's not
Bruce Lee no more and you see like some
other Bruce Lee look-alike walk away
watch check this out
dude look now they're the look at that
is that Bruce Lee
it was Bruce Lee but is that Bruce Lee
no [__] no it's not dude [__] no they
just that's how they decide that's how
they they decided to make the movie they
used see that's Bruce Lee that's Bruce
Lee and then they're gonna cut back
watch they cut back and it's the fake
one or their show see that's the fake
one he looks up they don't get a good
shot of his face they never really they
always shoot around that dude's face and
then check this scene out dude so now
the fake Bruce Lee walks away and now he
goes by the crew and he's gonna go to
his trailer and check out they put a
picture of Bruce Lee's face on this dude
and has a conversation with with some
dude ones check this out this is the
craziest scene of all time
fake Bruce Lee
he's gonna go to this trailer
watch
look at that's real Bruce Lee that's
real Bruce Lee they they can see how
that
this is look now fake Bruce Lee that's a
fake one
and that guy's a famous American actor I
forget his name but that's the real
boosting from another movie they spliced
that's another movie oh my God it's just
so it's another movie [__]
embarrassing look look at the picture
though right here this is gonna be
insane can you turn it up this reminds
me of
all right
very stubborn
their lead guitarist lost a couple of
fingers
real Bruce Lee another movie
another movie still that's the real
person
It's gotta have all those parts
still out of here
this is just awful what just wait hold
on wait the money shot is coming up
well
sitting right there by the telephone
that's a picture of Bruce Lee that's a
picture no [__]
that's him and fist the [__] Fury
exactly they just showed you two
different pictures of them with two
different haircuts this is something
that only a [__] and the work got out
right away when people left Friday night
they're like don't go see it different
movie and then they now that's the fake
Bruce Lee it is something that and they
did two or three more yeah with the fake
Bruce Lee yeah and the poor people who
went to see it listen man I was I I I'll
never forget him dying there's no
internet it wasn't in the newspapers so
we
actually had to go to Chinatown
and in Chinatown is where we found out
Bruce Lee was dead and they actually had
the newspapers with him in the casket
and then there were some of these 10
packs of pictures
so for four bucks you got ten boycotted
pictures the Chinese don't give a [__]
ever it was like Bruce Lee two pictures
from each movie and two pictures from
the casket
one with him you could see the casket
and the other one with like
Steve McQueen and James Coburn carrying
the [__] casket
and you think back now you're like how
much money these people make
well if this guy's name after he [__]
died
they made so many [__] movies you
know when you go to Blockbuster you see
boxes and they actually say the real
Bruce Lee
and you sit there and go how the [__] do
these people get away with it but
millions of people fall for that [__]
man I was seven when that Game of Death
came on I didn't know a kid can't tell
no kids can't tell no that was made for
kids that wasn't made for adults that
was made to beat [__] adults that
wasn't made for kids that was made to
beat [__] adults
they figured 100 adults to go to the
movie theater and 25 of them I asked for
that money back
that's what they pray
and you know what in those days there
was no computerized ticketing
so I can tell you 50 people came to the
[__] movie and steal 25 tickets it
wasn't like it is now that in those days
you gave me cash
I put the register I gave you a ticket
and I gave your friend here [__] I'd
love to see a documentary on the making
of Game of Death that would be
hysterical they had a bunch of [__]
they had them maybe they did maybe they
did I like you know he did Enter the
Dragon but part of the deal was that
they gave him all these movies for him
to produce and direct yeah but he was
losing it
none of the parts that he's in in Game
of Death or any [__] Academy
award-winning roles by that time he was
doing the voice too much he was doing
the cat too much he was trying to do a
different cat
what the [__] are you doing Bruce you're
killing me but you know what man it's
like Lynyrd Skynyrd who knew where Bruce
Lee beat that
was the martial arts still good with the
fight scenes still good in the movies or
were the garbage like well he well and
when end of the Dragon came out that was
his big movie that was on Warner
Brothers that was his first big movie he
finally he did uh a Fist of Fury in the
small Chinese label Chinese connection
small Chinese label Return of the Dragon
now that the production's blowing up so
then Warner but he kills Chuck Norris
everybody goes to see that that's
another one that you sit there going
what the [__] am I watching
but he had some pretty good fight scenes
plus he kills Chuck Norris and the end
of the Dragon was the big one he does it
he has full control he's like the man
Warner Bros said this is the
[__] man right here he he had
full control of that whole movie all the
fight scenes everything he had he was
the man then he dies
so he dies right before the movie comes
out so the movie comes out it's just
[__] huge it's like the biggest
that's the first thing I wanted that was
online yeah like by that time there was
a line look for the fight scene Enter
the Dragon the second fight scene is
possibly in the tunnel before Han
catches him when he breaks out he uses
every weapon known to mankind he starts
with the ball he gets the [__] sticks
that Lee talked about then he gets the
new Chucks that's all great and dandy
the other night I was home and it was on
and I watched the foreign
and I watched the first uh
couple minutes
right there with O'Hara right there
baddest fight scene ever you're not even
going to remember this lady now it's
1970 [__] three
this guy this white dude rapes his
sister put the sound loud put the volume
on Lee watch this watch Bruce Lee's look
on his face when he finds out who he's
gonna fight this guy raped his sister
and she killed herself look at his
[__] face
yeah okay so now this guy actually
knocks in the door and says bring your
uniform for the whatever and Bruce Lee
told them my side another classic line
now you're in the movie theater as uh
I'm 10 when this came out Lee
I'm a green belt in karate
and the whole school is there with you
mods don't head back
don't get back and now he got to use his
real voice no overdubs
well they had money for these
that dude's still alive
[Music]
watch his hands Lee
one shot pants
he can't even [__] believe this guy's
still alive Bob Wall Bob Walton he'll
come to your house and tell you stories
from the small 50.
same [__] move
[Applause]
what a great choice of uh uh like the
scene the way it's going down
block somebody [__] elbow on these
blocks here we go ladies look at this
stop looking at the things
look at this this is 1973 people you're
at the movie theater going [__]
bananas now yeah that was one of the
greatest kicks of all time
what oh hell but when he gets him with
the spinning back kick right here why
don't watch melee watch the spinning
back here kid watch this Lee textbook
Bam are you [__] kidding me
[Applause]
this guy's getting smacked around in
front of his [__] man another one
foreign
just died the black dude just recently
died maybe three weeks ago look at this
right here Lee oh you know what happens
to you incisely if somebody gets you
with that like that I think somebody
broke their arm on this yeah yeah one of
the guys sitting down broke his arm
but here it is his pure Steve McQueen
dropped a ball
well they have thermoses they have water
bottles in those days
look at this crazy [__]
there goes the elbow
[Music]
oh that goes to equal that room under
here
that's this is the shot right here
that's the look
you just lost your mind at the movie
theater your head exploded no there was
no weed necessary nobody could do kung
fu like this
acting was [__] awesome his his fight
scenes that's how he looks of this
[__] now look at him what what
the [__] do you want eyeballing me son
welcome
is the best diesel under there instead
diesel right here
ohara's treachery has disgraced us
that was [__] the greatest scenes of
all time that stands the test of
[__] time right now the way he
went when he broke the way he walked to
him like he's just like I'm gonna like a
father you know what I mean like what
did you do he just looked at him and
said you're not [__] serious are you
you're really not serious I just [__]
you up and let you live and you're gonna
bust two bottles yeah it was just
Sensational and he was dead a week
before that movie came out late
he died a week before that movie came
out it was already on the street that it
was a [__] masterpiece
and you know it was just I saw all these
movies at a place called Encino Tony or
the cinema if the cinema didn't have it
or we even wanted to see it it would
always whatever was at the cinema was
always a scene at the only he was on
bike you've been doing awake
but all the movies had Spanish
translations
the movies were in English but with
Spanish so all the guys that came after
him sucked so bad and the movies were so
horrible that you could take any one of
those movies like Kung Fu theater and
you could do whatever you want with them
they're all public domain nobody [__]
owns them you could take you could do
whatever you want with those movies
those shitty kung fu movies all those
Bruce Lee rip-off movies they're worth
nothing they're worth nothing public
domain all of those people they shot
Eddie I remember going to Puerto Rico in
1973 a couple weeks after Bruce Lee died
me and this kid named Jimmy Crespo
our parents were friends and on both our
families went but him and I had the same
agenda every day we went to the [__]
beach we went home we ate we took a nap
and then we go on a [__] Kung Fu
matinee
we saw Matt we were down there in nine
days we saw a different kung fu movie
every [__] day
that's how popular they were they were
coming out by the bundles even more so
than the American movies
my favorite movies I watched in Puerto
Rico work
the one-eyed short the one-armed
Swordsman
put a couple Crazy Ones out for a while
he was eating people's tongues and [__]
like that
uh Sunny remember killer be killed by
something Ryan like there was a
something they were trying to bust out
another Chuck Norris or some white guy
and the movie's called killer Beacon and
Chuck Norris his first three or four
movies were not bad guys
good men wear black Chuck Norris
he transcended and started doing like
you know what was missing an action and
[__] like that missing an action I'll
tell you what was his favorite movie
mine is
Code of Silence
Chuck Norris was [__] Dennis Farina
with a crazy drug dealer would give
people Colombian neckties the mob was
involved great story 1984.
I don't know what happened people
playing from time to time code is
silence Chuck Norris yeah that was it
for me Eddie Chuck Norris has a black
belt Brazilian Jiu Jitsu does he really
yeah through the machados he's he his
karate associate Association is Giant
and all the black belts are required to
do Jiu-Jitsu that's how evolutionary is
well what happened with Chuck Norris was
he was involved with something called
Tang sudo
and it was coming through though thanks
for those things to know when the
Koreans and when they got into it then
he took thanks to law and the other guys
took the mujaquan section of it which is
the same stuff basically
when I moved to Colorado
one of the first guys I went to through
the Colorado Mountain College
when you went to the classroom it was
him and Chuck Norris they had been The
Originators of that style and they broke
apart yeah and Bruce Lee was uh
originally a Wing Chun guy he was a
traditional martial artist and in Wing
Chun they generally don't believe in
kicking to the head because for whatever
reason you could you can get off balance
and you know fall to the ground so they
they like kicking low and that's what
Bruce Lee was about and when he met
Chuck Norris he's tank Sudan tanks who
does basically Taekwondo which means
lots of head kicks in spinning kicks and
Chuck Norris was responsible for uh
they've had debates and [__] you know
personally and Chuck Norris is the
reason
Bruce Lee started opening opening up to
high kicks Chuck Norris said hey man if
you can kick the head why not kick the
[__] head you'd Land one shot
in the head and that's a that's a grand
slam right there why not have grand
slams in your chamber you know what I
mean like why he unders you understand
you know especially like even in the UFC
there's a lot of guys that never kick
high they just they want they want to
stay standing they don't want to take
any chance because they know if they
kick high and they [__] up and the guy
takes them down that could be the whole
fight right there one high kick look at
Chrisman you know what I mean so a lot
of guys never throw head kicks or rarely
there's a bunch of current huge UFC
stars that just won't throw to the head
and that's the way Bruce Lee wants it
and until Chuck Norris convinced him to
well if you want to do TV and films you
have to kick to the Head yeah yeah for
the effect nobody wants to see six body
shots and well the guy's kid [__] well
that's exactly exactly they want to see
but I'm talking about personally for his
style right because in the movies Bruce
Lee was always throwing head kicks right
he was always filming yeah and that you
know that pissed off a lot of his
original uh students because his
original students came from the school
that Bruce Lee was teaching that you
don't kick to the head and don't do
fancy [__] it was all about just really
practical the best [__] like the best
shit's gonna be a head but to the face
that's the opening move elbow to the
face kick to the balls get a quick put
them out no [__] Jabs just two two or
three shots and it should be a done deal
if he's not done with the first two or
three shots uh your your style sucks
it's basically what the original was but
then once he started doing movies
and doing all sorts of [__] that he
preached against his original students
were like dude you thought it was a kind
of like you know in a weird way kind of
sound out but Bruce was like Hey listen
movies that's a different [__] thing
no one wants to see ball shots
constantly or or a headbutt to the face
it's really crazy [__] because I
understood the wing chunk Style
and the wing chunk style uses kicks in
sort of a way like Kempo
if you see the old really good Campo
guys
they block you
and then they throw a short kick at your
thigh
and with that short kick they step in
so that movement is really not wasted
do you follow me I'm boxing you unboxing
your unboxing you're unboxing I see you
I go to counter I'm gonna throw a punch
but while I'm throwing a punch
I'm throwing a kick low
wild it's a weird kick they have and
they even like it's a slap kick to go
and to move your hands and that's Wing
chunk then move your hand and just broke
and then they get out real quick but
they're starting to get out it's a
little leg kick that you actually
sometimes it throws you off you don't
expect it you know I'm very torn
and I don't I want to I want to
understand
how much of it is
uh Nostalgia because if you if like if
you're watching the movie today 2016
the the
uh everything is bad Direction acting
it's it's something some movies do stand
the test of time and Enter the Dragon is
when it's like Apocalypse Now okay it's
like The Godfather you know we watch The
Godfather you don't see shitty
production you see epic shots you see
epic filmmaking you go back but you're
right though most movies don't stand the
test of time you see [__] production
yeah but there's a difference between
like standing the test of time and these
are just like
I guess maybe it's because they're from
no China under the dragon watch you know
what and watch end of the dragon and
then no no no no watch Fist of Fury
first okay and watch his humble [__]
beginnings and then watch Chinese
connection
because Chinese connection already
launched them in the states okay after
Chinese connection Eddie he was huge and
now Americans are sitting there
was so big and made it to HBO late night
and then it ended up being called Return
of the Dragon and then yeah Return of
the Dragon but end of the dragon's
better than all that all that other
person
it's like Clint Eastwood's Spaghetti
Westerns you could not dismiss his
Spaghetti Westerns the classic Spaghetti
Westerns you know that he put his heart
into him there was really no dough
involved he had nothing going on here
his TV show got canceled he had nothing
to lose and if you ever have like you
like watching [__] you'll sit there
and watch Orange is the New Black the
nine hours right yeah that's good if I
have nine hours this guy's girlfriend
thinks it's good okay
so if you have nine hours like this week
I have 22 hours to watch TV
and if
hang them High the good and the bad the
ugly
or one of those films comes on I will
watch it I will run onto the balcony
smoke dope even if it's on AMC with
commercials
because I have the time there's nowhere
I can go with straws in my nose
those movies are so
you know you have to do it's white belt
[__] but you have to watch it to
understand what he did later on that's
why there's so many people that love The
Unforgiven
I'm an Outlaw Josie Wales guy that's a
Warner Brothers film
you're following me and so and at this
time he had put on this is when they
were shooting westerns all the [__]
time
Jesus Christ
yeah this is when this is when you you
you you you know he was what's that word
people use well you don't want to be
torn into something or the same role
over and over oh uh yeah I know what
you're saying and then he picked up the
the [__] uh whatever this then he
picked up the [__] uh
the the Dirty Harry thing
and then he went back to like the outlaw
Josie Wales I love Josie Wales like 76.
then in 80 something he put out The
Unforgiven
so if you watch The Unforgiven it's
great but if you watch those early films
you know all that early [__] he did that
was brilliant stockley it just takes
patience and a woman is not gonna watch
for you it doesn't really matter you owe
the Chinese you get two different dishes
you get a couple appetizers you get a
couple cans of [__] soda a gallon of
water and you put the food on the stove
and you pull on these three phones and
you really watch what America what in
the town what a great job they did the
same thing happened with Bruce Lee okay
Bruce Lee had a show called the green on
it
and the show got canceled
and then they came to him with another
idea for a show
but a man that travels all across the
country
and the word on the street was Bruce
losing a TV show and at the end of the
show he's going to do kung fu
guess what happened at the end the
network decided he was too Asian
and they didn't want to commit so they
got a white guy to play an Asians role
and that broke Bruce Lee's heart how
could it not so Bruce Lee ended up
getting a deal to make a show that
was released as the big boss
us it was released as Fist of Fury
okay but it's a really good film but I
feel the Chinese connection was a lot
better
when the Chinese connection came out
that was it that [__] put them to a
new level in the United States
why do you think they don't make these
movies anymore they don't have them they
don't have the
you know leave this these were
Independent films the three spaghetti
from westerns were the four he made were
Independent films right the three the
four movies Bruce Lee made
three before Enter the Dragon or
Independent films okay so do you
understand that it was a different time
it was a different place for this type
of [__] it wasn't about uh you know
budgets and whatever on the other side
on the other hand
the United States what are you doing Lee
what are you looking for you make me
nervous what are you looking for I was
just I'm just turning that mic off I'm
playing
uh
you know the United States at that time
is releasing
some of the greatest films they released
in the history of Senate right
but the first five years of 75.
some of the greatest films released in
cinema yeah from The Godfather to you
know Deer Hunter with Deer Hunter and
Taxi Driver came later on in 78 and 79.
so here's Bruce Lee fighting for his
life I mean if you look at the films
that got released from 70 to 73 74. so
he's going up against major he was going
to make major films now when he came out
with the with the United States when he
came out with Warner Brothers it was a
completely different game yeah he had
hundreds of millions of dollars of
advertising people were waiting for
Bruce Lee and all of a sudden the word
got out he died
which made the [__] movie even bigger
10 days before he comes out but to
answer your question now I know you're
coming from if you didn't grow up a
Bruce Lee fan Fist of Fury Chinese
connection Return of the Dragon you're
gonna see the [__] production you're
gonna see it because you're just like
you don't you don't have there's not a
nostalgic uh thing going on there but
Enter the Dragon if you don't know Bruce
Lee at all and that's the first thing
you see that stands the test time that's
high quality production right there
right and I uh but there's also a point
to be made for
him taking over the country it seemed
like like How could an eight-year-old
boy not love this dude going in and just
destroying an entire dojo
when I came from Cuba
on the weekends my mom always did things
she always did different things and then
we go back to the bar
and I still remember being a little boy
and stopping at a gas station and those
days golf
that gas station golf yeah you got a
notebook
and every time you go in there and got
gas they gave you a coin
and if you filled the [__] notebook
up with the coins you got something
and I don't even forget that I got those
coins and I wanted to win something but
it didn't matter because the Green
Hornet was coming on at seven
I still remember going home
as a four or five-year-old and watching
this Chinese guy and go wild yeah before
he made his movies he actually had it
was on an American show The Green Hornet
he was the sidekick he was like Batman
and Robin he was Robin he was running on
the Green Hornet and then once that show
got canceled really quick like within
maybe two seasons not even it got
canceled so then he went to uh China to
his father died yeah and that's when
they approached him and next thing you
know he left his family here and went
over there and he shot those films
because in China the fact that there was
a Chinese guy on an American show they
know who he was they he was huge he had
no idea from a shitty little shout he
was [__] huge he was a hero he shows
up to China in China and that's when the
movie houses started Raymond Chow I
think was Raymond he said he signed them
and started uh and and the first movie
he was supposed to be a co-star first
movie he wasn't the main guy but after a
couple weeks of filming and he just
[__] took over the camera work and
the fight choreography so the producer
said okay uh we're gonna rewrite the
script a little bit this [__]
this guy is gonna be the star they
changed it in the first movie he just
took over they're like oh [__] that's
the [__] man so they redid
everything and then from that point on
it was just he was on an Ascension to
like [__] but that
you see her now like
uh
people eat acai bowls right people would
need outside Ebola they won't give a
[__] they would appreciate them but
since it's a Brazilian Jiu Jitsu thing
people eat them it's a Brazilian culture
thing right well the same thing happened
in this country and Bruce Lee took over
and I said it one time in the Yari thing
he represented
all immigrants
so I want you to think of a different
time
you know you had Charles Bronson who
what color is Charles Bronson why the
ship what color is Clint Eastwood
same thing you know so
we really didn't
have we had shaft
black people had shafts Chico and the
Man chicken when the man came in 78-79
you know 77 but right then when Bruce
Lee came along he represented
everybody who was the little guy hope he
represented something else but what all
the other thing you saw was martial arts
was
became [__] huge
like I saw a magazine black belt go from
30 pages to 100.
you know like now people were into it
Judo schools were opening up kung fu
schools were opening up karate schools
opening up like when those schools were
still
nobody was still into Taekwondo
Taekwondo was that dude down the corner
they charge 85 instead of 100 not even
it's [__] I think I paid 50 to go to
Golden Rule karate in those days
Unlimited
but it made everybody more aware you
know everybody wanted to be it's funny
because they were talking about uh gym
Wars
you know people always talk about the
gym more is that you know down in Brazil
and at T and [__] uh
and uh what's this other one up here AKA
you know and I remember that in our
neighborhood which is much like Eddie's
in a lot of ways
not everybody went to the same karate
school
so Mario Diaz went to Food job by kung
fu
uh this other kid from off the block
went to like
goju karate I went to Goshen room and
this kid Glenn cologne was a black belt
in three things at the time
and everybody would eat dinner
we meet it Mario Diaz was a Chinese
Cuban kid his last name was spelled with
an e
and we would go to his basement and we'd
each do a form somebody would teach a
form
from their school like on Mondays Eddie
you teach something today then on
Wednesday you would teach something so
we'd all learn something from each
other's School
and then after about an hour we heading
it was odd
it was on when you're 12 and 13 you
don't feel dick
it was on we broke those walls we threw
each other's little sheetrock walls he
wouldn't let the father down there he
would have to put boxes around the wall
I'll never forget he called me one day
because it's over my father found
there was holes everywhere we used to
hang the monkey where I was up you know
what they are makihara Maki
is a skinny thing with a little two inch
thing and you stand in front of it and
throw [__] punches and [__] so we had
all the beams all [__] up we tried to
hang a heavy bag down there but point of
the story is Eddie I used to leave their
bleeding from my mouth every [__]
night
like they would [__] you up you know so
many Fight Club it was a fight club
without black eyes and [__] like that
you know what happened what would happen
is you would be light spotring okay and
then all of a sudden Eddie would kick me
a little harder than what he's been
kicking me
you know what I'm saying listen I got a
head out of here a little harder to me
just to let him know and now it becomes
this and there was no headgear
there was no hang things it was just us
no mouth guards uh mouth guards yes oh
really okay mouth guards yes
but it's just so crazy I went through
that whole thing I swallowed the growth
no Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
none the most foreign thing there was
was there was a black dude in the Bronx
that thought
the French kicking of picking that was
as crazy as it got how crazy is it that
uh even during that time in Brazil Jiu
Jitsu was huge you know all through I
mean the whole you know I guess from the
20s on really that was a Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu scene going on and the world did
not know about this
America had not seen it no but if you
really watch
Chinese connection he gets Bruce Lee in
an unborn Bruce Lee bites his way out
yep yep no no in the Chinese connection
and Enter the Dragon in the first scene
he puts a dude in an arm box puts a dude
in an arm bar it was a shitty arm bar
though whatever it was let's see that he
was in the ground already yes yeah you
could see that he was already knew what
it was just I wonder if he knew what the
Brazilians were doing I wonder if he
knew about every heard about The Graces
he had to have right he was this famous
martial artist he hung out with the most
famous of people he had to have known
about Brazil but he learned for sure he
learned some grappling from uh
um Gene LaBelle he learned a lot of
grappling there's like famous stories
where him and Gene were kind of [__]
around and jingle bell kind of just
tossed him up a little bit with
grappling
tell me if I'm wrong but how is it is it
okay to compare Bruce Lee to hoyler for
the UFC because I was watching uh like
that
uh like look back because I don't I
never I didn't see that whole other
match I don't know anything about the
big question
the big question is Bruce Lee the
demonstrations okay he did the one inch
punch and he must have done a lot of the
things
Bruce Lee was a great martial artist
for the movies
nobody ever saw him fight in the ring
you know never in the ring but he did
fight people on set like that because a
lot of them got the extras were actual
actual uh Fighters and they tried to
challenge him and there's been many
stories where he [__] people up like for
real like but not in a sport in a cage
or in a ring or anything like that he
wasn't into that there wasn't no [__]
phones with cameras right so nobody ever
got to see those footage so when when
you look at Bruce Lee you have to look
at Bruce Lee through two different sets
of eyes the reason why it's very hard to
sell Bruce Lee to somebody of your age
is because he's just a Chinese guy
that's a martial artist he did three
movies
kicks were tremendous whatever but the
production value and [__] stuns you a
little bit as a young guy hey when I was
20 I would not even think of watching a
black and white movie
the only black and white thing I watched
was The Honeymooners Twilight Zone
but that's
uh for me if somebody came to me and
said I want to start watching movies
give me 10 movies I would recommend
Chinese connection into the Dragon
definitely without even [__] thinking
twice because they had to see it but
they would go I had yeah it was great
Bruce Lee was great the other end of
Bruce Lee was because he opened up a big
Spectrum in this country
he gave people
little guys a chance little guys joined
karate karate schools went from having
three students to 25 [__] students
toward him and started refurbishing you
know flourishing you know it was the
classes were packed packed it was all
the impact of Bruce Lee
all those little sayings he would say
and everything
when Bruce Lee died that was a hard time
for me and mine in my house already I
was going to Chinatown and buying the
white shirts with the blue and the shoes
where would you wear those just out
everywhere to school
okay though I was [__] with dogs I
can't believe you're going to wear them
to my Mom's bar goose down by the
customers at the bar
I loved it I loved the whole thing when
it stood for
it made people get out of the house it
would work out you know and made people
throw kicks
it also made people go crazy like UFC
crazy
you know everybody who got into a
pushing match then got into a cat stance
and wanted to throw a karate KK so now
you're like Jesus [__] Christ
everybody I'm fighting is a [__]
black puppy and they really weren't they
were all just doing what they were
mimicking from the movies you know
right well and that's more what I meant
with hoyler is just the
I mean hoist voice I'm sorry yeah
with the just like the feeling around it
getting like getting people excited
about it getting people going to Jujitsu
classes like that yeah hoist definitely
change the world like in a whole
different kind of way he the the first
us the first UFC I saw I was doing
karate and I immediately dropped it and
started doing Jiu Jitsu like that was
that just blew Jiu Jitsu out the water
with hoist it
was revolutionary I mean I mean it's
been going forever we didn't know about
it nobody knew about it he came along
and gave martial arts even a broader
View
people have been coming over the years
and giving little Peaks into different
styles of martial arts or martial arts
they developed
but he really uh
you know [__] uh
gave it a different view this is Jiu
Jitsu here's this guy that's Joe Diaz's
size and he's on top of whatever and
this guy gets out of it and then
triangle is the guy I don't know what
the [__] the moves he was doing but
that's what I saw and I'm like that's
[__] amazing even though there's no
striking because that must be hard
especially no striking there's no
striking into Jitsu like with like uh
Bruce Lee you could it's like it's a
little bit more but exciting even if you
don't know anything about karate but no
horse crazy was the first guy in the US
first UFC champion right no no obviously
I was punching there in the UFC yes I'm
just I just meant Jujitsu as an art yeah
there's no punching in Jiu Jitsu as an
art as a sport because
you uh
you know brain damage you know right
most people
99.9999999999
of the world including myself didn't
want to go into a goddamn cage and go to
very few people have the balls to do
that the rest but the rest of the world
still appreciates the martial arts and
Jiu Jitsu especially you know if they're
into it so Jiu Jitsu is a way to
um it's like playing a game you know
it's like wrestling but instead of you
know wrestling the objectives to uh the
objective is to panic at his shoulders
to the ground for three seconds Jiu
Jitsu it's sort of like that except the
goal is to make someone tap out and when
you make someone tap out it's because
you put them in a Chokehold or some kind
of some kind of joint lock and that you
know although there's no striking just
that alone is pretty badass because you
got you know the game of trying to make
someone tap out is it's it's incredible
you get addicted to it and get obsessed
with it because the better you get at
that game that game translates to real
life even though there's there's no
striking in the dojo
I'll put you know if you do Jiu Jitsu
for a couple years the odds are in a
street fight against a guy who doesn't
the odds are so much in your favor so
much even though you've never thrown a
strike in the dojo no punches no elbows
but you've been doing Jiu Jitsu for two
years on the street even though there is
striking if your Jiu Jitsu is on point
you're not going to need striking to
immobilize you know this douchebag you
know right yeah I hate to talk about
this on the show
because I don't like to centralize the
show
if you watched Anderson
against Daniel cornmeal last night
you know everybody's saying that Daniel
Cormier should have done a lot more
damage
his jujitsu
chapter on his balance off
Anderson yeah and this is so he got him
in a lockdown throw water he was trying
to do a lot of things I don't understand
all the other variations of your style
of jujitsu
but I saw that but I saw that he kept
all of his balance off
you know just that technique just that
little thing of my jiu jitsu
he's been doing Jiu Jitsu out more and
this is over 20 years something like nah
I don't know about 20 15 more like 15
let's say 15. Jesus Christ in Brazil
do you know what he knows Lee
even if you break both his wrists and he
grabs your legs like that
could survived he survived he lost the
fight but you know what he didn't get
knocked down he didn't get hurt because
Jiu-Jitsu helped helped him survive well
don't you think that is also just to
point out how good Cormier is that he
held down Anderson like
an Olympic wrestler right yeah so he did
by getting on top by taking Anderson
Silva down Jujitsu isn't the art of not
getting taken down so if it was if Jiu
Jitsu was the art of not getting taken
down against wrestling which is the art
of taking someone down then he has uh
Daniel Cormier beat Anderson style but
that's not the style the style Jujitsu
just get the fight on the ground it's
better to be on top but if you're on
your back and your Jujitsu is is um
decent you still got game and um here is
you could look at it make no mistake
about it Daniel Cormier beat Anderson
Silva but he didn't finish him and uh
Anderson Silva is mostly known for his
striking his Jujitsu is like always his
backpack plan he's never trying to do
Jiu Jitsu he's trying to strike he was a
striker we started learning Jiu Jitsu
because he was an MMA you have to but
that's not his forteus Forte is striking
so but he knew Jiu Jitsu good enough and
he is a black belt to survive an Olympic
wrestler's onslaught of strikes Daniel
Cormier karmia could have thrown as many
elbows to the face as he wanted to he
could have punched him a thousand times
in the face if he wanted to take him
down and just but he didn't he took him
down and got wrapped up and tied up and
it wasn't some Roundup times it was a
specific Jiu Jitsu tie-ups to survive
some guy trying to bash you down some
giant Olympic wrestler wanted to pound
if he could have put 10 elbows right
through
um Anderson someone's face he would have
did it but he couldn't
I mean I I found the fight it wasn't as
entertaining as I would have liked it
but there was no difference between that
fight and the uh Brock Lesnar fight yeah
you're right it wasn't it wasn't very
entertaining at all good that's that's
not I was talking about survival the
survival that he did entertainment yeah
it was it was pretty I wasn't it
[__] would have done what Anderson did
in half guard and did the lockdown he
wouldn't have got punched in the face 15
times right because the kid wouldn't be
able to set up
he would not be able to [__] set up
first of all he's got a [__] Mountain
for his stomach right away you're off
balance
right away you're off balance
so if you would have locked his knees
together and just [__] hip bumped
himself he would have had a mount again
right when he's going through a punch
[__] hip-hop at him again right hip
bump him again that's what Anderson was
doing Anderson was picking him up he was
two inches away he can't go back and hit
him when I when somebody comes to me and
they go what do you think of this fight
I repeated that guy
and I always go with the guy who's got
the Black Mountain Jiu Jitsu if he's got
some [__] Coral Stripes I even go
with him more because I know he's been
in hell
I know he's been in Hell he's been in
Hell a thousand times those guys are in
[__] hell once you see him at the
brown belt level they don't even
breathing heavy and he doesn't even
breathe it Eddie peaches and [__]
looks around like a Momo and looking at
it and you know that's just a complete
different gift
so I always use that I knew I either
thought Anderson was gonna go out there
and knock him the [__] out or they were
going to ground them until he got him
down
and I could see that he wouldn't let
he's been he's a [__] professional
and this in silver wasn't the champion
for seven years because he sucked guys
right okay so that's what you know the
advantage is that you've been as a
[__] Blue Bell you've told people's
balance off once you get to the brown
belt level that's the first thing that
goes is your balance
you're like what the [__] am I doing all
the way over here I'm across the [__]
room
it's it's just a beautiful art it's just
that a beautiful [__] art how many
stripes you got on your belt right now
three you got three stripes damn yeah
dog but I'm terrible you're almost I did
good tonight
yeah [__] what did you go to submission
today uh no I did something better than
the submission would you pass too deep a
half [__] flings probably my deep
half is
I just throw the [__] nothing
wrong with that I'm not holding on to
them and recovering my guard
that's what I should be doing get them
into side control from that [__] so
once you sweeping what happens if you're
three feet away from me
but you got but you're not on top and
you sweep them but you don't get on top
and controlled they're three feet away
from me they land three feet away from
you so I gotta figure something
you gotta you gotta not use so much
power so I come into my knees and I
might mess around with them and I try to
control them with my knees clenched and
then they fall for the bait and I stick
my hand under that leg and I pick them
up and I try to get the leg and I hide
this arm and then I Walk This Way and
then I spin real [__] quick
but that little spin has been throwing
them out my Loop and I gotta start all
over again man I want to see a video of
you rolling man no it's time
horrifically bad oh come on oh
horrifically bad
but you know what man I'm gonna do the
surgery to breathe a little better I
think I'm gonna go see the nutritionist
and really work it down to the
centimeter do you do you generally get a
submission each time you you roll one
maybe one every one one at least I'm
going
first submissions which would it would
which is the submission that you you get
more of mustache the most popular
submission I got is I trick people with
the I love the college show I'm a fat
dude
so I ain't doing much out of the
ordinary my game is not going to be much
or ignore the ordinary
so I try to put one hook into your right
side
and then I fake like I'm gonna go for
the [__] arm bar
and I pull
and before he knows it I get my other
hook in there and I let my light help in
my garden I swing for that sound like a
[__] gorilla so it's 300 pounds
hanging on your neck anyway nice and
like just try to sneak my hand up
laughs
every time I go for an arm bar [__] it
up do you ever get that bow and arrow
choke from the back you ever do that one
you're gonna get someone's back and
choke them it's funny the other day I
was on Joe's podcast and we were talking
about my Roy Nelson
doesn't get people's back when you're a
heavy guy it's very hard to get people
back this really gets in the way
so you're very rarely I don't know I
haven't never it's in a big heavier type
guy
take a lot of backs you know it's too
many steps even the arm bar is too many
steps for me if I got you in that
compromise sometimes I put my knee over
your belly but it's to trick you into a
Kimora
I don't really go for arm bars I don't
like dropping my back like that besides
if I get you right I might break your
arm by mistake so I don't even [__] with
those
I like triangles that's what I have to
do fake the arm bar and go for triangles
I got strong legs from the mount from
the bottom I'm trying to work from the
bottom yeah I don't like no no nothing
on top to me that's not what I got
involved in the yard for the art for me
was
to learning to be really good from the
bottom
you know to learning to be really good
from the bottom every time I'm in class
I always take the quickest people and
they pass my garden [__] me up but I
don't give a [__] because eventually I'm
gonna get them
I'm gonna figure out how to do my legs
and give me that my extra inch you know
Matt Baker your buddy has a good point
if you're not on your back they can't
pass your guard
so it's kind of weird I'm trying to put
all that stuff together so
nice it's a journey for me man but at
the same time it's helping my stand up
and it's helping me because
like I told somebody I was ever sitting
here
when you do when you go to karate you
[__] uh
figure out you can't throw a kick six
feet so your coach says on the weekends
hang a hook on your [__] roof
put a strap and hang your leg and learn
how to stretch your legs a little more
you know or you don't have enough
punching power in karate if you're a
kyukasan karate guy so they make you do
bench presses and hit more stuff you
know
when I joined Jiu Jitsu I found that I
couldn't do a lot of the stuff that was
physically but the mental part of it was
the part that I was really disappointed
with myself
because I had this fear of people on top
of me
and that's the worst thing I hate is
when I have fear or something
some things you have fear of and you put
them together in your head and you go
you know what I could deal with that
when it comes with but somebody getting
on top of you that can happen any day
when you're walking down the street with
your daughter and your wife and your
child
and what are you gonna do
you gotta know what to do you know what
I'm saying I'm going into my 50s
there's no way I'm going to karate chop
you're doing for a flying sidekick
through the [__] damn
but if I could single you and throw you
down and get on top of you put my
shoulder on you and put my forearm in
your neck I got three minutes to get to
the car before you even see random's
apples coming out of your [__]
[__]
uh breaking somebody's arm real quick
from getting the car I like those little
things about Jiu Jitsu choking somebody
you know you could choke somebody with a
winter jacket it's a college joke yep
t-shirt picture College you know with a
[__] t-shirt
so these are all the things that I'm
getting older that
I didn't want to have those fears I
didn't know that my cardio was just
horrific from smoking reefer and
becoming a vertical breather I had no
idea about these things that popped up
in my life at 40. there's no way I could
be a farm and have these shortcomings
the shape of the world today I got to be
able to run 10 minutes I'm at a park and
they start shooting at him
you gotta pick your kid up and run with
that [__] she's 50 [__] pounds or
something yeah she's a human kettlebell
so what I do is when I walk out of
school I pick her up and I walk with her
just first block and my goal is to make
it to the office I don't even make it to
the office
will that make it like three doors down
and [__] like that
because those are the fears I couldn't
have with a daughter
man it's it's amazing hearing I didn't
really uh know this before I mean you're
really you're really looking at
at fatherhood and um
you know super realistic way like you
know what I mean you gotta you now you
got a daughter you got to be able to
protect her but you know that's what I
tell people all the time like just at
the very least there's a lot of things
you could do you could learn Jiu Jitsu
for but at the very least to protect
your family at the very least you want
to protect your family if some [__] goes
down you're out at the movies you're in
line you're with your kid there's a
[__] douchebag and something's going
down
I mean who knows if the Jiu-Jitsu is
going to work all the time but you got
to do what you got to do or can do to
shift the odds in your favor and just
one year of Jiu Jitsu just one year and
time flies so how many times just one
year
I don't even I'm gonna name two off the
bat
how many times have you seen somebody
take a punch
get over somebody
over commit and get trapped in a nine
bar I've seen two how about you
three times
alfredo
against Brazil and Joe Lauzon had one
that was
I think against the black kid from the
guard is that what you're talking about
but after I punch you in the [__]
mouth hard
I go backwards I hold on to that arm
right there as I'm going back I pull you
into me I over commit you you're like
you [__] idiot you grab my wrist I
start hitting you with this and I've
seen Joe lose on arm bar somebody while
he's getting beat the [__] up
and I've also seen fatal punching away
at [__] verdum when he nailed them
with an arm no no Guerra and Mark
Coleman there you go so I figured that
that's a great protection thing right
there so if you could take one punch
which we all can and fall backwards and
suck this guy in of him to grab you with
three beers in him
or whatever the [__] drug he has in them
he doesn't even see you hang going
around and pulling your elbow and next
thing you know your leg swings around
and you [__] lean back and pick up
your hips and you're here
and you ah you [__] I you [__] you pull
your leg around you stick your boot in
his [__] mouth and you kick the rest
of his [__] teeth out while he's
yelling and shot you get in your car and
you're going nobody knows nothing
you pull three blocks away you see a
homeless doing the trade him sneakers
hey how about a brand new favorite
they got a red stripe that means you're
a [__] animal I'm saying and you have
to look at little things like that when
you have a family
and when you get older you don't want no
fears
I didn't want no [__] fears every
time I got on my back
I would think the world was that
negative problem I thought the world was
ending any problem
you did a lot of uh working out and
athletic stuff when you were younger you
always say you wish you did too when you
were younger why do you think you didn't
do it or something it wasn't available
nothing you didn't Jiu Jitsu became
available 93 94.
not for me I lived in Boulder at that
time and I was taking taekwon thank sudo
mud on Juan it wasn't available yet in
Boulder
it didn't become available to me until I
moved to Los Angeles and then a year
later I met you and it became available
to me but I didn't know what the [__]
you were talking about but between doing
a [__] unborn snorting coke
your arm's gonna work tonight you know
what I'm saying I ain't [__] coming
down at 6 30 at night
having a kid will make you think about
stuff like that though for sure I mean I
remember taking Draco when he's one or
even younger just in a stroller every
day taking him for a walk and there was
this one dog that is behind a fence in
our neighborhood that would come up and
bark and man it was a German Shepherd
the thing would probably [__] me up but
when my son's there
there'd be no fear and I could just
imagine just grabbing that dog it's jaw
and just breaking it open you know what
I mean like when you have a kid there is
no fear Mike Tyson came up to you and
[__] with your kid you'd jump on that
[__] without a hesitation that
wouldn't even be a delay you know when
you have a kid you just jump in and you
just go to war or die
well for me it was a lot of other things
it was
it was I was getting a kid so I wanted a
new beginning for myself of doing
something
and I also wanted to do something that
was hard for me that wasn't easy
the last thing I ever did that was hard
for me was comedy
that just wasn't easy you know today
I woke up this morning I got up early I
did some writing I got really stoned
and I uh ah my [__] knee got tight my
wife left for church I went to the weed
store
no I went to CVS to pick up my
prescriptions
then I went to the weed store but I left
my cell phone in the car
and uh you know I'm getting surgery
tomorrow I may have to take two weeks
off from Jiu Jitsu Eddie I can't tell
you how bad I feel
because I was on a roll for the last six
months over there on a roll on a roll
like not killing people but at least I'm
showing up yeah it's been consistent you
know nothing like being consistent he
sees me twice a week if I'm in town
three times if I'm [__] not working
four times
if the Sunday class because the Sunday
class is my favorite class because I
always learn something small
you know what I'm saying like last
Sunday I learned how to do a proper hip
Escape after three [__] years
like I always learn something small
stupid but that's how good that guy is
on Sundays
and now I gotta take off for two weeks
which means I'm gonna be huffing and
[__] puffing all over again now when
I go and getting anxiety it's the last
thing I wanted to [__] do
I always saw wanted my daughter to be
old enough
and for me to show my daughter that I
was doing something
you know what I'm saying that three days
a week I have a responsibility to do
something
and she'll say eventually where the [__]
do you go
my answer how you go to Jujitsu and then
she'll say let me come with you one time
and you go down there and she sees and
maybe she'll get involved in something
maybe it's not Jiu-Jitsu maybe it's
Taekwondo but at least you're setting an
example for your child yeah I'm saying
yeah
it was all those little variables man
I wanted to do something I had never
done before
I'm not gonna go rest so I can't get
drunk down like that Eddie I'm on 300
[__] pounds
I'm like I'm gonna go learn how to shoot
a bow and arrow because I want to go
[__] hunting for a week and kill
animals and [__] so I had to find
something else
I had to find something close to my
house I had to find something that
wasn't a very competitive school where
people want to go in and take my [__]
head off and break my arm I can't work
can't [__] work with a broken arm I
mean accidents happening you know what
I'm saying accident [__] happened
you land room your wrist
and Jiu Jitsu was the answer for me I
think you know and I'm too old to do no
[__] gee they'll kill me I see those
people I did it one time my office they
grabbed my neck my whole body stopped
that's the time I put the [__] 2x
rash guard not that Mia
a [__] two-way that's how fat I was a
2X rash guard tapped me out I had to
have walls that come in the back and
take it off I can't [__] breathe with
this goddamn thing it's funny
but I enjoy it as you saw I brought
copies of Jiu-Jitsu magazine I read that
on planes like an [__]
look at little moves I basically got it
for the diets and they have a little
nourishment tips they got to get really
good nourishment tips in there
everything else I can't do without
drinking valve does you know I'm saying
I look and I go that's great
thanks for the move Andre I can't do
that type of [__]
where's Tony Bennett [__]
[Music]
I wanna be around
to pick up
we're gonna take a little break somebody
no we just do this ten minutes let me
come back with a new subject wait oh let
me go pee again
Jesus Christ because you're drinking
beans [__] you gotta take little
sips of water
are you ready for another start
absolutely [__] yeah
as you used to do with me
you gotta eat these Stars I can't be
eating Stars this week maybe Wednesday
I'll eat some Stars that's gonna be here
you have to wait until Wednesday I don't
know let's see how I feel I was gonna
say that's good let me give some shout
outs my main man the lolinguses
spooky always getting my back that sexy
[__] I saw your boy Freddie Correa in
Vegas with his beautiful wife my man one
by one podcast holding it down Tracy up
there in Canada looking sexy in a
[__] Crystal Johnson looking
sexier my main man Timmy Holloway and
Timmy Jr
Mike Land
and my man Raymond bazio son of the
[__] greatest drummer
Terry bosio I'm gonna give you a [__]
shout out to don't forget the no
expectations tour starts seven July 21st
at Flappers in the evil room 50 people
I'm just gonna be trying out my [__] if
you can make it come down and not I'm
doing it again in the following week I
will never do the rest of those [__]
day tells that for you
very exciting
it's a
it's gonna be interesting watching you
build this special I'm very excited well
the set I had in Vegas on Friday wasn't
that good I tried some new stuff and
it's missing the Diaz umph
so I gotta find something more [__]
um Norton you ain't I'm from hot enough
but just from the surgery you've been
pissing this much or this is always
I don't know maybe it is a surgery I
don't know but [__] I always piss a lot
I'm reading an article on BJJ uh
jiu jitsu
the magazine
and they're talking about different
tournaments
first of all congratulations on ebi
thank you very much seven happening next
Saturday night at seven o'clock yep
Pacific Standard Time on UFC Fight Pass
when you receive and that's where they
can order it that's where they can pay
it or whatever you could you if you have
UFC Fight Pass it's free or if you just
if you don't want UFC Fight Pass and you
want just to watch ebi you can order it
at ufc.tv one time deal I think it's
9.99 you don't have to commit to if I
pass you've got animals again this year
Eddie Cummings yep we're doing the
featherweights for ebi 7 uh Eddie
Cummings is the champ Geo Martinez is
coming back he's the former champ Joe
Soto's coming back he was in the finals
when Cummings got the belt uh Rafael
Domingos is dropping down to 45 Denny
procopos is dropping down to 45.
uh we got the return of Bill Cooper he
was he was the baddest American Jiu
Jitsu player you know eight ten years
ago and he's he's back he's incredible
shape
ARA muradyan who's a go-court
chavichians top featherweight super
leglock guy we got Chad George who's a
who was a black belt slash MMA fighter a
Barrett your sheet is going to be in
there Alex Acklin
oh Mikey main
um Sergio Hernandez who has the craziest
style ever he's got Eddie Cummings first
round Sir John manners and Eddie Cummins
the first fight of the night is going to
be insane Sergio Hernandez has got a
style that no one can prepare for I mean
he's just donkey guard slash rubber side
mount slash reverse closed guard I
rolled with the guys it's insane his
Style's the first match ebi 7 next
Saturday on Fight Pass gonna be [__]
crazy and plus we have some special
matches with the return of Grace Gundrum
I'm trying to find the best girls to go
to the best girls how old is Grace now
she's 13. Jesus Christ so we got you
know Rafael Mendez is right now the best
Jiu Jitsu guy on the planet his Prodigy
Janelle takachek that's the best girl I
could find and that's the best school
around right now as far as like the ibjf
tournaments she's going to jump in and
we're going to see how she does against
Grace maybe Grace gets smoked I don't
know I I'm on a quest to find out how
good grace really is because she just it
just amazes me with with her skill and
her her decision making and her
technique it's pretty crazy that a 13
year old girl could be she's like a
virtuoso violinist you know those little
13 year old violins who shred they don't
shred for a 13 year old they shred
period they're just amazing and and
that's what she is she said you get to
Prodigy and we'll see how good she
really is against aoj the art of Jiu
Jitsu Raphael Mendez School their best
13 year old and that's going to be right
before the finals that we're gonna who
knows who's gonna be in the finals of
the guy tournament it could be Eddie
Cummings versus Joe Soto or Geo Martinez
or Barrett Yoshida but right before we
find we find out the champion of that
night which uh there's twenty thousand
dollars up
um for the that's the grand prize
we're gonna see grace Gundrum versus
Janelle to contract that right there is
gonna that could steal the whole show
right there no
and your wildest imaginations did you
ever think there was even going to be in
the ebi 7. no man I really didn't I took
I didn't know there'd be an ebi too I
didn't I was never planning on doing
that a fight promoter type guy it's just
it just [__] happened I just fell
right into it just started uh just
trying to think of a
a rule set in Jiu Jitsu that would be
like entertaining for the average UFC
fan the average guy that doesn't train
Jiu-Jitsu likes to UFC there's millions
and millions and millions of UFC fans
Jiu Jitsu is a huge part of the UFC why
isn't there any UFC or Jiu-Jitsu shows
they can you know cater to like 10 of
those UFC fans for like 15 20 but in
reality it's less than one percent of
UFC fans are interested in Jiu Jitsu
shows so and uh tip for me I think the
reason is it's the point system the
point system is not a fan friendly it's
great to develop skills certain skills
like guard passing and sweeping the
point system really emphasizes that
that's the most important part of the
point game is those those sweeps and
those passes that that's gotta be
[__] on point you want to win a
points championship and which is a
beautiful thing sweeping and passing
it's huge super important you eliminated
that
which is really interesting because
I like I said I read an article in there
and then you could break down for me a
little more because I don't know Jujitsu
Lango
said that they're doing more tournaments
than IE with ebi rules and I was like
[__] Eddie's on to something
if all these people are doing I think
there's two other tournaments happening
with Epi rules there's a lot of
tournaments that have adopted ebi
there's a bunch there's a bunch and I I
want them to use it use it I don't own
those rules just use it let's let's make
Jiu Jitsu um fun again you know because
really submission only is what Jiu Jitsu
really is when you when you train Jiu
Jitsu at your school no one's keeping
track of points you're trying to submit
each other if submission only is not new
it's what Jiu Jitsu is it's the essence
of Jiu Jitsu and the point system that's
like unnatural Jiu Jitsu but again the
point system I believe is important
because it does stresses certain skills
and passing and sweeping is very
important so dew points tournaments to
focus on those very important parts of
Jiu Jitsu keep that I'm not trying to
stomp out a point tournaments I think
Point tournaments are important but
they're just not fan friendly you can't
put points tournaments on TV like chess
I always use this analogy chess is a
very cerebral game very prestigious
Noble people play chess kings and queens
play chess but you just can't put chess
on TV you're not gonna put the world
champion I can ask you a question
how long is ebi
what do you mean the show how long is
the production of ebi like one shot give
me red on round ball again give me uh
Pistol Pete or Julius serving I don't
give a [__] who you give me just give me
a red on Rambo how long is the whole
production
show of
because this is the problem I have what
is how long is the whole production of
baby guy
um it could be any we've had shows that
uh
it lasted two and a half hours okay I
went downtown in between how much down
time in between in between we generally
not that much down time at all we just
we bang them out we go pop pop we don't
we don't have time to waste I go to your
[__] ebi it's exciting it's in a
beautiful theater the lighting is
beautiful
but after the first whistling
I'm just sitting there watching Chinese
because I'm not up to that advanced part
of Jiu Jitsu there's nothing wrong with
you or anybody
I just don't really know much about
levels
I don't like people touching my [__]
feet that's why I'll never become a blue
belt I'll stall that white belt for the
next 10 [__] years I'll get four and
a half and three quarter Stripes you
understand me yeah I just don't like it
I don't know I just don't like people
touching my feet like a fun guy on the
toe
hit it Lee
now
it's so funny that uh
oh it right there
before we tell you why these thumbs are
down our hands are extended
this is Pete Maravich
the greatest playmaker and passer in the
game today from Theo Vaughn's Hometown
also playing with the New Orleans jazz
notice the fingers notice the wrist
notice the hand it's firm finger spread
a follow through
just on a simple chest pass now Pete in
throwing that pass do you really think
about that when you do it or does it
become automatic well actually it
becomes automatic but three basic
ingredients in throwing any type of
passes fingertip control backspin and
follow through all right now do me a
favor give me an intro and give me three
moves a minute a piece in between the
[__] fights
oh what leg locks are yeah I see what
you're saying one minute a piece for a
guy like me so if I go to Jujitsu and
I'm telling you I'm confused I love the
game well the leglock see the thing is
with submission only the the main
difference between submission only and
the points game is generally in The
Point Community
the leg locks are frowned upon they
don't they don't like leg locks but in
the work Community I'm sorry the the
average BJJ school is not into leglocks
they don't teach leglocks they don't
they look at them as too dangerous dirty
they teach them but they don't they
don't exercise they don't teach them or
emphasize I go to your school as a
purple belt I learned this curriculum
from Scott Ross Michael Myers one of his
[__] games with the glasses I go to
your advanced classes I get a brown belt
my leg locks are good I go to
cabrinas okay will I be [__] them up
with my leg locks and my style of Jiu
Jitsu with those leg locks you know it
all depends I mean does he work on a lot
of like blocks from his school they
don't no they don't because in the
points tournaments they're illegal so
it's a waste of time
so if I put a Geon and went to an ibgf
tournament because I got a heel hook no
good it's illegal you get disqualified
no [__] yeah you can attack the legs so
I can't do that move where I put on then
do a Kimora and twist on your leg nope
even if I'm a purple belt well it's
illegal generally when does a strut
become legal you could do toe holds I
think as a black belt and you know you
could do knee bars you could do no no
nothing twisting and no reaping the leg
um but uh and submission only you could
do everything this is what you need to
do how you doing my name is any Bravo
the 10th Planet system is a little
different advanced in more systems let
me show you the basic like what boom
thank you
come back defensive basic like what why
do they spin I don't even know where the
[__] they spent and they're both holding
each other's foot what the [__] I don't
like wanna I gotta hold your foot and
spin All These Little Things answer them
for me in 30 seconds
it's hard to do in 30 seconds that's how
about a [__] minute you're right
you're right that's a great idea just
say it and then let's edit it yeah yeah
it's like Twitter yeah when I get on
Twitter in the morning I got you [__]
your mother in the ass I hope Bazookas
but then you got 180 characters you got
to start chopping that a and that duh
and that b and eliminate that comma it's
the same thing with these yeah until the
person gets educated that's what you'll
have over any other people
you know and it's like all right I'm
switching to the chat I got to think of
BJJ in 2016 is a contail away from being
on SportsCenter at two in the morning
if I gotta sit down if anybody over here
get high and put on SportsCenter to do
karate
with the swords and [__] and you're
sitting there going this is worthless
these guys will get beat up especially
right now this is the worst time to
watch sports center because it's hockey
and that's it and a little in baseball a
little bit of baseball
so from now until August there's nothing
so what you mean to tell me is let me
talk to you from the hard Sports and the
people the [__] kennel show that you
put on every year with those ugly
[__] dogs for four hours
we can't celebrate Jiu Jitsu things are
there for an hour again
it's got to be to go on television and
to basically educate
you know the UFC educates you with the
three-point system it's a scoring system
there's three judges but that's all you
know the way I I look at it though it's
a great idea but the way I look at it is
if you're a UFC fan and you can follow
the UFC and you you understand what's
going on in the ground
um yes ebi is more technical because
it's all groundwork but it's I figure if
you're a UFC fan you'll understand this
enough you'll get it
um we're not I'm not generally thinking
about attracting people that don't know
anything about jiu jits like them
they're gonna have to catch up you know
what I mean right it's like NFL it's
like the NFL I'm not talking about yeah
yeah I'm talking about somebody who
maybe isn't Jiu Jitsu and never seen it
to that level yeah you know I'm talking
about if you really really really want
to put this on TV yeah you got to break
it down from somewhere yeah you got to
break it down for yourself the leg block
game is it's just as vast as Brazilian
Jiu Jitsu in itself you know Brazilian
Jiu Jitsu you attack the neck you attack
the arm a [__] is all legs it's the
same thing in their joint locks it's
like you know if you you know if you
attack someone's shoulder or elbow it's
the same thing as attacking someone's
leg the same thing it's not like a
different person it's your body you have
limbs you have arms and legs and you
have your neck Jiu Jitsu should be about
all of it and uh you know the Gracie's
on especially on Helio's side with Hicks
and horion and hoist they attack the
legs not as
um as uh as deep and as vast as like
what John danher has done like they take
they took it to the the next level you
know there's been [__] there's always
been catch wrestling who teaches at
black house down there
I don't think there's actually teams I
think I think team no Guerra because
team no Guerra has no Garrett down the
assembly Mike Maxwell's on that team
okay and I've had discussions with Mike
he's like I don't even [__] with this
[__]
I just attacked the legs they're right
there yeah
the great thing about legs is
um you don't in Jiu Jitsu before you can
think about a submission if you're on
top you got to pass the guard if you
can't pass the guard very hard to get a
submission there's still a couple things
you can do but generally you have to
pass the guard to submit and on the
bottom you know uh generally you can
submit guys off your back but generally
you want to sweep and pass but with lead
locks you don't have to sweep and you
don't have to pass to get a submission
you can go for legs anywhere you don't
have to sweeper that's what he said he
goes why am I going to arrest it with
you for 10 minutes yeah
the party's over the problem is with leg
locks if you get too leg lock heavy it's
not uh the the absolute smartest style
for MMA like if you're going for legs
that means man you're you're not tying
up your opponent's arms that means he
could elbow you or punch you so in MMA
it's that's why I never really got heavy
into leg locks until the last couple
years but um General in the beginning of
my G 10th planet we were always leg lock
friendly always allowed leglock guys to
go after and reap legs and I encouraged
it but personally for me I didn't want
to get too heavy with it only because I
was focusing on
uh more MMA style but you know now with
the rise of submission only game I'm I
dove head first into leg locks and the
whole 10th Planet Jiu Jitsu Association
has been transformed
um we're we've always been heavy on the
rubber guard and twister and lockdown
stuff and electric chairs but now we're
also heavy on leg locks last cuts for
him first oh really I'll give you the
last like that who's the guest here he
is tonight trust me
Lee likes these I don't mind going last
no I love leg locks man I'm I'm sold I'm
100 into it man I love him my students
like the girls are doing them kids are
doing them we got everybody on leglocks
right away it's funny how you told me
the story when you were like a blue but
you went to a tournament and you went
for a heel hook and people started
throwing shoes I went for a tall because
I used to be in the toes I saw a Ken
Shamrock video a long time ago he's in
jeans with some Japanese stuff he did a
Toe Hold so this is like a 94.95 so I
started I was a total fiend back in the
day and uh the first the first
pan AMS in the states
they shipped 500 Brazilians into El
Segundo to do the very first pan AMS and
there was a bunch of Brazilians and I
went for a toe hold and the riot started
the right almost started they started
throwing shoes and water bottles at me
and and Johnny Machado comes I have a
toll that everyone's going nuts
screaming at me and yelling they were
doing Brazilian chants and throwing
shoes and uh John Jock's brother John
he's come running and he slides him back
because you gotta let it go
and I have to talk I'm like oh
look what's going on everyone's going
nuts so I let it go and the guy beat me
but um yeah leglocks are really frowned
upon for a while now they're more
accepted
but you know after saying how high you
can take the leglock game with Dan hurts
Danner has done over the last 10 15
years leg loss I'm like [__] I want some
of that so um it it uh it takes your
overall game to a whole nother level
because yeah you want to pass and yeah
you want to sweep but there's guys that
you can't pass the guard and there's
guys that can't sleep you're gonna run
in the guys you can if you're really
good at leg locks you're still in the
game you're like [__] to pass me go
after your legs and it's a whole
different game it's a beautiful thing
man Jiu Jitsu and leglocks and [__] are
all mixed up together [__] you don't
know what's gonna happen it's a
beautiful thing and in the submission
only game since there's no strikes [__]
leg locks are crazy important super if
you're not if you're not on top of
what's going on with leg locks and the
submission only game you're gonna get
God you just cannot go forward unless
you understand the entire body you just
can't be half the body like arms and
neck you got to be full body for
submission only because they're going to
come after your legs got like Eddie
coming to Gary Tony come after you like
[__] you could if you if you don't know
what's going on 100 you're gonna tap
yeah
kill that [__] Savage it's Sunday
night [__] we're getting the week
started right you understand me you want
another one
look at your eyeballs that one right
through your [__] skull didn't it it
really did
you think Uncle Joe is [__] around
before surgery
I'm going in there all somboat and you
could watch the entire ebi Library one
through six on Fight Pass in any time
too the whole thing
we got uh the ebi 7 countdown show
that's on my YouTube channel that I just
uploaded about it between it last week
oh the really really oh nice
yeah the ebi 7 countdown shows but 25
minutes it'll it'll give you a rundown
of what's going on next Saturday so if
you watch that countdown show you're
going to be pumped up for Saturday
you'll understand I break down all the
competitors even if you don't know who
they are like at first you will
after that countdown show
I'm happy doing this [__] it just shows
the the
your Evolution you know the evolution
and then looking at that magazine I saw
all these people at ebi rules
I know uh Channel sun is doing a
tournament now and he's doing ABI rules
too he called me Chelsea and said hey
man you mind if I borrow your rule set
and I said [__] yeah go for it I want
everyone to do it so just you know you
so you start seeing like tournament
flyers and then there'll be ebi rules
you know what I mean it's like it's like
prison rules kind of you know what I
mean a basketball prison [__]
impressive ready because for years they
tried to do something and you just took
it over with an idea so
you got to tap yourself on the back
again like you know what's gonna be
crazy is ebi 8 which is September 11th
it's going to be a 16 instead of an all
you know Beast tournament with dudes
it's gonna be a 16 13 14 year old girl
tournament with Grace Cora Alyssa Jessa
Jasmine the Beast Danielle Garcia
Janelle takachek 14 year old girls oh 13
and 14. [__] amazing ebi it's called
the females it's going to be all woman
show but the tournament is going to be
13 14 year olds all bad we're gonna find
out if Grace is the best we're at ebi 8
we're gonna find out if she is maybe she
gets knocked out in the first round who
knows you know because there's we got
there's this girl named Jasmine the
Beast Johnson who's gonna I'm featuring
her against Danielle Garcia this
Saturday as well because because she was
going to be in the tournament I wanted
to bring it bring her in and uh and uh
you know let people get a get a glimpse
of what she's uh what she can do she's
115 pounds she's 14 years old 100 15
pounds Grace is a hundred pounds so
that's the weight that's the weight
limit for the eb-i-8 is 115 but core sex
in there she's 103 so there's going to
be these light super Light technical
girls going against these super athlete
14 year old girls that are having a hard
time making 115 pounds you know what I
mean so it's gonna be like Rocky 4 it's
gonna be like Drago and and uh against
Rocky seriously man
very interesting the growth
of Jiu Jitsu I mean there's schools in
Burbank I don't even know about
I rolled with a guy from Checkmate
Burbank I didn't know Leo Vieira check
him out check magic his best girl
Danielle uh Danielle Garcia she's
actually going to be she's fighting this
Saturday again
Long Beach he was out of Long Beach you
know what I don't know she's Czech Matt
but I don't know there's a bunch of
check mats I don't know which one she
trains at I should know that but I know
that she's Leo Vera or you know what
she's probably up in Victorville there's
a check map uh
Marcelo Mafra he's out in Victorville
that's where Daniel Garcia is from she's
from Victorville she's a 14 year old
girl she's going against Jasmine the
Beast
215 pound 14 year olds with superb Jiu
Jitsu there's gonna be some crazy [__]
core sex gonna also have a special match
she's going against Zoe Childs this is a
a rematch
so on top of the 16 guys the
featherweights we're gonna have three
special matches with uh girls that are
going to be in ebia I just I wanted to
give people a glimpse like I said of
them before we do uh that all-female
show
it's gonna be nuts man it's just really
funny get your girl in there too good
girl what's her name Jessica flowers
it's just really funny where you've
taken this game and uh
I know for a long time you struggled you
know people didn't like the reef a thing
people didn't like the the [__] 10th
planet
and now you got the system you got them
over a barrel they're using your [__]
rules you know what's cool man is uh
this is it was a cool weekend in so many
ways and on so many levels but one of
the coolest things was you know like I
said the ibjjf they held a tournament
there at at the UFC Fan Expo and um I
ran into Seoul like Leo Vieira I ran
into him talked to him Ron carnero uh
lucatella a guy from Grace you make all
these guys that um
uh you know I was never really close to
I wasn't like ever like we were never
buddies and texting each other or
anything like that we just kind of never
really said anything we passed by each
other and just occasionally said hey or
whatever shook hand but uh it was a
really good time man I had really good
conversations with Leo Vieira that's the
guy that crushed me after I beat orange
I tapped that hoiler in 2003 Abu Dhabi
but the very next match Leo Vera beats
me like a hundred to nothing and uh um
and we had a really good conversation it
was it was a it was a very pleasant time
at uh at that ibjf tournament met a lot
of people out of Brazilians that I never
knew before uh it was it had a really
good time it's uh
you know you
you won the contemporaries right now
you're one of the guys right now
you know I've had conversations with
Alberta when he was telling me when he
met you when you guys were blue belts
yep yep or something like that so you
know I met I met Brody Stevens when he
had a [__] Public Access show I see
Brody now I gotta give him a hug because
I knew him back then and this is the
same thing with the people you're seeing
now yeah with Alberto crane we met um at
the a Santa Cruz tournament that they
had a Claudio Franza had the Santa Cruz
tournament I forget what it was called
like U.S Nationals or something and I
met Albert Alberto crane up there at a
blue belt and he was the only one with
the video camera and he had a big one of
those video cameras that records like
VHS you know the big ones and he had one
at the tournament and he said he would
film my matches we met him kind of hit
it off and he filmed my matches and it I
remember and then he lived in New Mexico
and he said he would make me a copy I
remember writing him and she was like
this is 1995-96 and asked him hey do you
have that tape when are you gonna send
that tape and he took so long to sit and
I just wanted to watch it I never had
any video of me competing I didn't
videotape anything this this is a you
know no one had video cameras back then
you had to be rich keep talking
oh now you gotta pass
when are you gonna do Jiu Jitsu Lee when
you thinking about it um I did it for a
while and oh you did where are you Joey
yeah oh the same place he was at um at
uh vmac I like vmac
but I um I don't know I I listening to
Joey and you and everyone who talks
about Jiu Jitsu there's such a love for
it and I just
couldn't I did I didn't have it but what
I had that Jiu-Jitsu Place uh they had
kettlebell class once a week so from
that I found a place that Joey actually
used to go to as well but it's a
kettlebell gym so I do that three times
a week now but if you could press a
button right now right you go if you
could press a button that gave you the
skills to put people to sleep and break
their limbs and totally immobilize
people in control if you could press a
button that gave you that boom would you
do it or you said nah oh absolutely of
course right why why because it'd be
awesome wouldn't it be awesome to like
actually no I totally remember so you
got to look at it like this some people
some people turn away from Jiu Jitsu
most people most I'm I'm gonna yeah
you're like most people absolutely
you're like most people people that like
Jiu Jitsu are my in the minority you
know why it's just all about how they
look at it you know because you could
some people uh tapping getting submitted
it's in our DNA for it not to feel good
nobody ever gets tapped down and it
feels good it wasn't I I did a
tournament that I knew I was gonna get
killed in it was it was fine I don't
mind getting tapped out I just
I don't know man it's just not something
that I was physically good at
and I know most people aren't when they
start
but I don't know I I did you feel that
like did you feel like everyone was
thinking you just suck no no everyone's
always very nice but you just said
earlier that you would press that button
because it was awesome because yeah but
then it would be awesome to take into
account my arms that came so you gotta
look at it no but you got to look at
look at it like this this is coming from
a guy that's been teaching Jiu Jitsu for
a long time I've seen people come and go
um I I there have been lots of P most
people are react like you this just like
[__] that I'm not good at this I can't
do this and I'm not having fun I'm
losing all the times like why is this
fun I go in here and I get tapped out of
[__] that why is this how is this fun
getting Tapped Out it sucks it's in our
DNA for it to suck and when you net but
when you all you got to do is focus on
uh being able to do to someone uh what
they're doing to you oh man all you
gotta do is just know that you can do it
so you don't think you could do it but
you can do it but you think you can't
you think you can't but I'm here to tell
you I've never met anybody ever that
just continued to do it and not get
better at it little by little so you can
do you think like it was just too hard
for you you can't figure it out and it's
too complex I I think it was a fun thing
I think I fell in love with kettlebells
and I just wasn't enjoying because you
thought you couldn't get good at it well
they'll probably have a good amount to
do with it of course most people think
they can't they just can't do it most
people
um they think man it's just not worth it
you're gonna get tapped out all the time
yeah you got to get it and that's like
anything in life but you know when you
first walk into something that's outside
your comfort zone I call the guy up
first
I drove by there 15 times
I was done with kickboxing
and I had a bunch of options I could
call you I could call a bunch of people
I said you know what
I don't know this guy let me give him
the 50 bucks go down there because if I
don't like it
I don't know I don't want anybody to
know I even tried it
and I went and then we spoke and he
taught me the grips and
he taught me uh when I did the hip
escapes the room just started spinning
and we talked a little more and he
taught me a basic scissor sweep
I thought it was interesting I got in
the corner I'm like that was interesting
but I'm never gonna go back
um
and I went home and then I did a Ben
Franklin close you know what that is
when you put a piece of paper and you
put lines down the piece of paper
right
the advantages and the disadvantages
with Jiu Jitsu for me
you know obviously I wrote out of shape
but obviously a real commitment and I
wanted to do something different so I
went to a night class
and that was [__] rude Letty
Peru
because I'm I'm 50. I don't have energy
in the [__] nighttime all my Energy's
done in the daytime it's tough for me to
learn the moves but he taught me a a
pass a collar pass where you double up
the legs that you throw them over
and I could do that but again I walked
out and I'm like I'm not coming back in
here again
but you know me dog
I said I'm going back down to Monday
night and on Mondays from 8 30 people
don't like it because he makes you do
jumping jacks and burpees
I would do whatever I could do push-ups
10 Jumping Jacks and stop I would run
some laps I'd walk some
and that was the biggest mistake of my
life
that was like the time of St Patty's Day
1992 I got on stage and I'm Coke I
thought it was cute
that was a big mistake
and I know not to get high or nothing
when I go to Jujitsu because I would
panic when somebody got on top of me the
weight would just make me panic
I got sleep apne I can't breathe on the
bottom
but I started thinking what if somebody
gets on top of me on the street though
I'm gonna die
I'm gonna die I can't die because I
don't want to do this
and that's what made me go back between
you and I I don't have the aptitude for
it
when I played football I had after two
three days you know you learn your
[__] formations
and you learned to block this guy and
Tackle this guy as he comes around with
basketball I had to think with baseball
I didn't
and I'm Cuban I didn't have the aptitude
to play baseball with Jiu Jitsu I was
completely out of the game it was like
me going to a technical school to learn
mechanics
I'm not a normal mechanic you know it's
like it's like uh when you um
like with your experience with comedy
you know that if a guy starts doing
comedy and he goes up to a couple open
mics he's like [__] this I got you know
I'm not gonna [__] do this it's just
too hard I'm gone but you know like you
know like man you know whether you tell
him or not you're like you can do this
you just gotta [__] work you can do
this most people think they can but they
can't I I knew I could like my that day
my first day at Jiu Jitsu I got wrecked
I have 37 times got wrecked but instead
of doing what most people do most people
like [__] this how is that fun that's
not fun most people are like they're
gone but the way I looked at it is like
Survival on the streets I knew that [__]
who cares if this guy these guys beat my
ass one of these days I'm gonna be able
to do that to a dude who walked in the
first day that was the goal oh my God I
just want to be able to do what that
dude did to me you've been training four
years and you look like a [__] nerd
you know what I mean like you can do
this and goes hey train hard for four
years I'm like [__] I'm gonna be able to
do this too so I didn't care about
getting tapped like the more I got
tapped the more I'm like [__] yes I'm
gonna be able to do this and I got
obsessed and all I wanted to do was my
goal my first goal is to be able to put
a clinic on a dudes who who's been
training one day then after like six
months of hard training I was able to do
that it took maybe six months maybe even
a year before I can just do whatever I
wanted to that dude you know but time
flies so a year goes by like that but
you you actually can do it there is
nobody on the planet unless you have
some kind of serious like
um
who's in a wheelchair he's in a [__]
uh exactly you got it you still with
your girl what happens when you go out
and someone starts [__] man you want to
be able to [__] handle the guy
goddamn your business man you want to be
able to and Jiu-Jitsu will 100 100 give
you that confidence like if anything
goes down you're like I got this
[__] I wreck them every day you
can do that you you know I'm not you
know whether you go to Jujitsu uh again
or not it's not none of my concern at
all I'm just telling you I'm just giving
you a like I'm trying to and I'm never
gonna bring this up I'm telling you the
truth you're treating me like why I can
get really good at this man I couldn't
you could say you could have it'll it'll
you know what Jiu Jitsu will do when you
say when if you stay you'll start to
realize that [__]
I'm constantly taking these moves that I
suck at and getting pretty good at them
then getting really good and then
mastering them and it becomes
unconscious and then I'm doing it to
this move and then all these moves are
in different parts of development you're
like [__] if I just keep practicing all
this they look what I could do it's like
then you realize you could do that to
anything you're like [__] I anything I
want to do I can actually do when people
say that oh you can do anything you just
got to believe in yourself that's
actually true like it doesn't mean that
hey I want to be an NBA star you know no
it means that if you want to get good at
basketball you could actually get way
better at basketball than you are right
now you can get good at it not to play
in the NBA but you could do anything you
want to do and man why not have the that
the power to and the skills to put
people to sleep and break their bones if
you had to if you got kids he did a
mercy snapped him into shape Mercy made
him do it and maybe it'll maybe it'll
it'll take a a kid for you too but
one thing the main objective I thought
Jiu Jitsu had over anything I had done
even comedy
that really got my dick hard about it
the other day
I'm on the floor
my hip Escape I get the guy into my God
something happens
we gonna scramble and my arm got caught
and I go ah
and my little purple belts brown belt
looked over at me weird
and after the class
you know how many times this guy's talk
to me any maybe two times
he came over because what happened to
you before when I got my [__] shell
and he goes let's let me see this you
know somebody goes let's go on the back
and we took a stick
and we worked with this stick for 20
minutes they told me to take the stick
home and do this by myself for 20
minutes
he didn't look for a five dollar bill he
didn't wanted me to give him free
tickets to the comedy store
he didn't want nothing from me
and one thing I wanted from Comedy one
thing I wanted from my criminal friend
one thing I was always looking for was
one a family
but B I was always looking for sort of
like in his Brotherhood and I really
found it with jiu-jitsu more so than
coming believe it or not more solving
company
when I walk into where I go
I'm good to go that's my [__] house
the phone don't ring
I don't want to talk on the phone I
don't get text I don't get nothing
it's my aisle I take it really [__]
serious when I go in there when I go in
there I'm the fat white belt in the
corner I'm not Joey Diaz the comedian
I really like that I like that I like
that hour of
nobody has to take a [__] picture
nobody has to talk to me about auditions
in fact I'm asking people questions hey
don't get me in your guard to that movie
the media day you know what I'm saying
like and people actually go yeah nobody
says [__] you
you know some kid came up to me that
they go stalked my [__] cousin called
me says you're going to Nashville he has
a school they want to train you
when I was 418 pounds how many people
emailed me and said we want to train you
this weekend
a week before I go to a town now I got
an email from somebody who says bring
your gear I like to train you at my
school and I'll say is it far and if
they say yeah I want to do it but if
it's close I'll do it if it's closer to
school I'll definitely do it
it's very interesting that's one daily
one day that's what turned me on the
most about it that I'm just a fat [__]
in the corner who does eight hip escapes
and he has to get up and breathe and he
starts from scratch and it doesn't
bother me at all because it brings me
back to reality
it brings me back to the reality I like
to be young you know what I'm saying
it gets old to go out and people want to
take pictures it gets old
for people to laugh at your stupid
[__] jokes you know what I'm saying
there I'm just a guy in the corner
that at first I couldn't even make the
whole woman now I do the whole warm-up
you know
today I got submitted one time and maybe
I got the guy in a college joke
but I was happy that those two
uh
those two
deep halves worth like I went right home
and wrote it down
like they really [__] work and they
would textbook both times like I
practiced it so many times a drill class
now I hook his leg pick him up I'm gone
boom I'm On Top It's All About Numbers
it's like now I love half guard
I love half God I pop up I grab his back
I turn myself into the throne and keep
expanding it doesn't stop no you're
gonna keep growing a year ago do you
think I would put somebody purposely on
top of me Lee are you [__] kidding me
I actually pulled something on top man
throw his knees up and he get under him
and [__] pull him up again then I
hold him there and I breathe a little
bit then I walk his leg out then I
[__] spin backwards like a [__]
you know and I love it I love it that
should be some animation right now that
you're saying today
because I can't eat no [__] aspirins
because tomorrow I'll bleed the death
so uh that's why I'm really sorry so I
enjoy going uh I wish you a lot of luck
with the ebi this weekend thank you very
much I'm happy they could go to Fight
Pass you could either pay for the Daily
which is 9.95 you can just sign up a
pipe bypass and everything's on there
you could see [__] uh Popeye fighting
Pluto in 1922 they got everything on
there so it's not a bad [__] deal to
be on especially if you're of UFC
playing Lee how you feeling dog those
bunkers got this although everything
goes to me but yeah UFC Fight Pass is
great I signed up for it for the this
past week and they have like the where
are they now fights they have like all
the other they have they obviously have
ebi but they have a ton of other
organizations and I think if it's a
one-time fee of 9.99 it's the same price
as one month of if I pass
so might as well just do Fight Pass
yeah yeah your choice whatever you want
to do some people don't like to get that
and I signed up for subscriptions they
just feel like weird about it I'm at
corusc she's she's really cool too she's
gonna be good Brothers I watched her
like crazy submission video so she's
she's who Cora Cora yeah yeah
it's weird uh she's got some she's got a
new weapon that no one knows about she's
really good at some [__] this girl
everybody is that prepares for quora
they prepare for her rubber guard
because if you get caught if you get
caught in her guard she she is
has one of the best full guards on the
planet even for a little girl it's it's
super high Advanced which he's doing
um so people are always trying to stay
away from regard but now she's got a new
weapon she got a new one yeah she's
really good with it it has nothing to do
with guard wolf Jiu Jitsu you were
raised by a stepdad
you're in a relationship with him wasn't
that great what you told me over the
years did he passed or is he still alive
that stepdad yeah I have no idea no I
think he's still alive yeah I would have
I would have heard if he would have died
because he's uh my sister and my
brother's real father so I would have
known if he would have died he's still
alive if crazy today I found out that my
stepdad died he was like my own official
stepdad
it [__] killed me for a minute
because let me tell you something I
hadn't talked to him in a few days
so this morning I got up at five and I
rode for two hours
and then about six seven thirty I
started calling my friends on the East
Coast
and I called him at eight o'clock he
didn't answer this [__] always
answers he always answers even if they
even sleeping
so I hung up and I said I'll wait 10
minutes and he'll call back he's one of
those people
so he always calls you back he didn't
call back
so when my wife left to go to church
with the baby I had to go to the weed
store
and I had to go to uh CVS to pick up my
Percocets and all that [__]
and when I got back in the car I left
the phone in at the weed store and I was
in there talking to the girl
and I saw the and you know who else I
called after him I called my best friend
that's a funeral director
because he's a Freeholder this is
something you know how you and I talk
sometimes and you're like Joey I was
just telling somebody about you and you
called yeah synchronicity so it was the
same thing I called and if you look at
my phone I called Carmine first
I like all the gear venary and I talked
to him he was sleeping it was 11 o'clock
and I know what the [__] are you doing
this league because uh I got up early
ran some errands and I'm taking a nap
now throw some baseball games some [__]
and I said all right man just checking
in with you love you and I hung up the
phone and when I got out of uh the weed
store he called and people I was like oh
and I knew it
I knew it already
like I didn't need a genius I called
Anthony first and he told me here and
Karma and died that I called Pete and he
told me
Karma and dad this they talk to him they
called them and he said he was in the
bathroom to give him five minutes they
didn't answer the door
so he had a heart attack on the way in
now I gotta tell you at first
he was 78 he was done
he was done you know when he was
starting to lose his mind he was going
to bed at six o'clock and calling me at
one of the [__] morning
you know he would get up at 12 and start
dialing
and he would wake me up at three like it
was nobody
cocorini what are you doing what are you
watching what's on TV I didn't want to
hurt his feelings and tell him I was
sleeping
so I would talk to him for a little
while and I'd hang up the phone and he
called me back 10 minutes late and asked
me my zip code
then he would hang up and he'd call me
again so he was starting to lose it
but he would always tell me you know
he'd always told me on the phone I was
his adopted son
and today when I got Frankie on the
phone Frankie Goes when he passed I went
over that Coco and I I don't want to
make you feel bad I wanted his wallet
and he had a picture of me from The
Longest Yard
this dude was my dog dog you know it's
it's it's hard to
and I've never told these stories
because I was always ashamed of this but
it's hard to uh
you know Joe Rogan put me on the map I
did a few movies but Joe put me on the
map
Carmine and life put me on the map
because when I moved to Jersey I was so
insecure I wouldn't go out
so when I stuck up for his son he liked
that and I started going to his house
because there was weapons in my house
and drugs and cash I wasn't allowed to
invite kids out of my house when I was a
kid
like you'd come to my house you had to
wait on the porch unless you were
Spanish and you know about Santeria and
stuff then I would like yeah
but if not I had to explain it and I'm
not the mood to [__] explain it you
know what I'm saying
we're going on in the [__] date I got
a break for you while there's a dead
chicken
I'm not in the [__] mood so
but when I when I went to his house the
first time like I went ate dinner with
them and then the second time I went
back I'm like you're hungry yeah
go in the refrigerator and make yourself
a sandwich
like I had all access to that [__]
house as a kid you know
that's not where it goes I'm a Spanish
dude
you know what I'm saying like I'm a
Spanish dude so he had already thrown a
beating on a guy
for his son and I was there and then he
ended up throwing a beat on another guy
because of me and his son
so now the word got after that was a
carmine so nobody would bother me dog
and even all those years when I was
causing a lot of problems Carmine was
furious at me but they would call him
first before they wanted to talk to me
so this is one story there was this drug
deal named Mundi
and his partner had a gas station his
name was George yamaco
and his brother had a gas station Cuban
dudes and they would bring fruit up but
before they put the fruit in they would
put Coke on the truck and they had this
very successful cocaine operation
so one day in Georgia I could never
approach him directly I robbed this gas
station one time when I was a sophomore
without a gun he didn't know it was me
and my buddy so we never really [__]
with George yamaco but he was mutual
friends and a friend of mine
and one day my friend said to me George
you said that if you want to [__] with
him you got to talk to this guy named
Mundi
this Cuban during day Monday so I
started dealing with moonly and one man
that was beating him for like an ounce
well Monday went nuts so George yamiko
went and talked to my friend's dad and
my friend's dad said listen I can't help
you
talk the [__] Conway
so I got a call from Carmine one day and
he goes hey man
listen I don't know where you're in I'm
like using you anything but some drug
dealers came talking to me today you're
on some type of money
what do you want me to do here
like what do you mean what do you want
to do here he goes do you want to pay
them
they're like well not really and he goes
what do you want me to do I go up there
I just talked to him
you know just tell them that
and he went up there and talked on the
people never came looking for me
but he always took care of me all those
years from way before my mother died
till
yeah
we did the documentary
so it just uh
I could sit here and cry and be a
[__] phony [__] I already crying I
got out of the way
I can't go to the funeral but I love the
guy it's it's so crazy the gift I got
growing up that my parents were taken
away but God taught me the gift of
friendship like it's a weird gift to
describe to people it's a very very
weird gift to describe to people
when you have no blood and what people
have done for you you know what I'm
saying usually you need to be blood with
people like that
so it was a great gift that God gave me
I'm good with it and that's it I just
wanted to dedicate this show to Carmine
he uh made me laugh growing up a lot and
when he shot the guy seven times in the
back that was the best because he used
to always tell me if he want to shoot
somebody and buy them all for dinner
growing up all the time we were kids if
you want to kill somebody you want to
get away with invite them all for dinner
and shoot him
and when I was 18 that's exactly what he
did he shot a guy in the back seven
times in self-defense
and he got away with it he lost his job
as a cop but he kept his pension
you can't beat that [__] story in any
little strip club on fire
so as we were kids we used to call them
the torch
because he lit this strip club on fire
we'd always ask him if we've had him if
he had a match and he tells us to go
[__] ourselves
come on you got a match go [__] yourself
you [__] [__] insulting me like that
a lot of good times I think Robin he
treated me like he had four boys
and whatever his boy's got I got one
time he called me up he could come over
I went over there there was a brand new
300 India motorcycle waiting for me
whatever this boy's got I got
and that was way before my mother died
in fact in the eighth grade he called me
to tell me to come over to tell me to go
run into my house and tell me that my
mother's house was getting busted by the
[__] Union City and uh
Newark police department
he goes go over there and he didn't say
it like that and he was going and tell
your mother I said father clean the
house she's gonna have a visit I knew
what he was saying to me
I ran over and told my mother when the
cops got there it was nothing
very interesting the life we live in
Eddie bravissimo I wish you luck next
Saturday what time does it start 7 P.M 7
P.M Pacific Standard time just like the
UFC next Saturday night lisaat what's
going on in your world [__] you've
been very quiet tonight
I'm I'm just a very uh intrigued by the
conversation yeah and indeed I'm good
it's a
I I was very lucky me Karma and it's
very sad
um was he still working
no they gave him a medical release
because you got sugar diabetes and his
foot turned purple
so they had to send them home and that's
what was really that's what he what did
he tell us
when we were there we go Karma and you
still work and he goes when you stop
using it you lose it
and it took him six months to die after
his job so
if you're old don't think you're
retiring keep your job especially if
you're single your wife died or whatever
and at least keep your mind occupied
and that's the show folks let me uh we
got [__] sponsors tonight as usual
the show is sponsored and they also
sponsor ebi my main man Chris over at Dr
Sarah from the [__] bag he sent me
that I used to religiously I have a it's
I'm a man of a thousand Pockets listen
if I get bulldog with this [__] datsu
Sara bag the cops will never find them
there's a thousand Pockets don't give up
after the 80 second [__] pocket okay
you got a place for your your mouth
guard water an extra water I put protein
powder in a little container I put it in
there so after the [__] Jiu Jitsu I
have 26 grams of protein I got my wallet
I got my [__] cell phone I got my
keys I got an extra set of [__] knee
pads I got so much [__] in that [__]
bag I got an extra belt I got an extra
geetop he said he gives you an extra bag
to put your dirty [__] in there so on
the way home mix it with your regular
[__] datsuzara is way on top of you and
it's all hemp and it's all Hamming
what's better than the [__] fanny
pack I got I listen that fanny pack I
take it on the road
of my weeds vapor pen
[__] aspirins no spray tissues hand
sanitizer I put so much [__] in that
[__] fanny pack the last 10 flights
it holds all of them I use those hemp
pants that they make tremendous I love
them
it's awesome the top doesn't fit I
haven't tried to buy I wear the the
hempkey pants uh when I ref for ebi as
well last show I did anyways
and uh they're gonna they're actually
our main sponsor for ebi 7. so it's
perfect hemp gear come on how could you
not be here and things get mad you smoke
the [__] bag and make believe you
high you know what I'm saying anyway go
to dsgear.com right now tell them Uncle
Joey essential what do they press Joey
and you get five percent off your order
start with the Franny packs they got 15
t-shirts they got [__] hoodies I mean
they got stuck and it's all hemp all
high quality Betsy Ross type [__] you
understand me go to DS gear right now
and go to the box and press in Joey boom
five percent off and tell Chris Uncle
Joey since you're right also this is my
favorite all of a sudden one person
already contacted me and said he loved
it let me explain something to you have
you ever been frustrated trying to buy
tickets online like really frustrate you
want to go see Black Sabbath you want to
go see a baseball game most sites make
it complicated located and then they try
to sneak in a huge fee at the checkout
that's why you need to try seek geek
they made it easier than ever to buy and
sell Sport and concert tickets okay my
personal experience with seed geek is
very easy I have not used them yet but
my friend heard it he said he wanted to
give them a try and he said it was
fantastic seek geek is always the first
place I go to look for tickets to a game
or concert all right and they got the
seat geek app on your phone you could
use it you know to look up the tickets
whatever the hell you want to look for
whether it's a game whether it's a
preseason football game whether it's a
concert seat geek has taken all the work
and hassle out of shopping for tickets
and I'll tell you why it pulls all the
tickets available on all the sites into
one place so you can save time and never
ever ever Miss A Deal even better every
ticket on sea geek is given a grade
based on value so you can immediately
find the underpriced seats that's the
secret and before you buy you can use
seek Geeks detailed maps to see the view
from your seat that's a website you
understand me best of all seek geek is
always honest and upfront about the
price the most important thing they're
going to save you money unlike StubHub
seek geek always shows you the full
ticket price from start to finish and
there's no by the ways there's no
surprises with a huge fee at checkout
all right this is what I'm gonna do my
listeners right now today write this
down I'm gonna give you 20 off a rebate
of your first seat geek persons all
right so to get your 20 rebate on
tickets I'll tell you what you got to do
download the free seat geek app go to
settings tab and click add promo code
again
add promo code at the promo code telling
me
c-h-u-r-c-h church right there and C
geek will send you twenty dollars after
you've made your first ticket purchase
it's that easy download the free seat
geek app and enter promo code church
right now I get the 20 off and I'll tell
you what it's going to be the best
ticket buying experience you've had in
years I want to thank SeatGeek I want to
thank Dr Sarah always my people over and
honor taking care of you with the Alpha
Brain again 10 when they pressing the
Box Church boom there you go so again a
shout out to sea geek a shout out to Dr
Sarah shout out to on it and thank you
very much for listening to uh podcast
tonight thank you very much for the
concern on the surgery you know what I
don't want to do it but I got to do it
and uh I'll be breathe a lot better I
don't know what the [__] my voice will
sound like next week when we do a
podcast but we'll take our chances don't
forget September 21st is first night of
the flappers it's at Flappers this is
the no expectation tour I go up there
with a notebook with topics and we start
doing the special together it shoots
October 15th in Rosemont and you're a
part of it all right so if you're not
there I'll see you at the next one at
the [__] Flappers or it's at the ice
house I don't know where the [__] it is
yet I'll keep you posted see you this
week Eddie Bravo thank you good luck
with Epi thank you on UFC Fight Pass Lee
syack get your [__] together this
happens to you because you're not in
training on off nights I'm fine hanging
out with Mom and holding her hand and
you still got to do 10 Stars when I'm
out of town I don't mean either yeah
yeah all right I'm proud of you all
right we'll be back Thursday or Friday
or whatever the [__] I feel like maybe
Wednesday night stay black have a great
night I love you Cox Hunters
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
sweat
ers
[Music]
the boys
okay
foreign